this is jocko podcast number 285 with
echo charles and me
jacob willink good evening echo good
evening and also
joining us tonight dave burke good
evening dave good evening
all right so we are going to dive into
some work that i have been waiting
to dive into it i i waited because
i wanted to do it justice i waited
because i wanted to
i wanted to be thorough in covering it i
waited because there's a lot of work to
cover
and going going into this
this particular book books series of
books
articles individual the more i read
over the years it it got better and
better it kept getting better and kept
making more sense to me from a
from a tactical battle war perspective
from a leadership perspective
from a how to lead
perspective and also contrarily like a
red cell
type how not to lead
from a relationship leadership capital
perspective and a jiu jitsu perspective
so so basically i was just seeing
everything in my life wrapped up in in
this particular
this particular individual and his work
and on top of that so that there's
another podcast that i've got waiting in
the wings or it's going to take a series
of podcasts but
it's waiting in the wings i'm super
excited to do it but i can't do that
podcast until i do this podcast
or at least this podcast or at least a
couple podcasts on this individual
this one man highly influential man a
guy named
bh liddell hart basil henry
liddell hart you can probably guess if
you don't know who he is if you
know military history and military
strategy and military theory
at all you know who he is if you don't
know who he is
you can probably guess that he's british
because he has the first name basil
right sure i mean that's a pretty
british name
he didn't go to buy basil i guess he
went by bh i guess
i'm guessing um that's how he writes his
books
mother's maiden name was liddell she was
scottish
um you know born and raised i guess on
the border of england
the heart side the liddell the heart
side was farmers
[Music]
he was he was went to some really nice
private schools in so he grew up in
england born in france but grew up in
england
he went to some really nice private
schools the first
one of the private schools that he went
through is called saint paul's which is
in london
and it was founded in 1509
high school founded in 1509
okay so you're that's just kind of crazy
when we think about england
uh then he ended up at cambridge
university which by the way was founded
300 years prior to that in 1209
1209 12 09.
well he left cambridge university when
world war one broke out
volunteered for the british army he was
in the king's own yorkshire light
infantry i'm glad we did that light
infantry podcast recently
dave you timed it all you you liked that
one didn't you i did made you start
thinking about some light infantry
because it's a mindset yeah it's not
just a it's not just a way that people
are trained it's a way of thinking
yeah and i got to pull that real time at
muster i listened to it all the way to
muster and put it into my brief what was
that point that you made
well the whole point behind that like
the largest theory when you went into it
was
the size of the force is not the
deciding factor so there's a lot of this
if if you have a smaller force doesn't
guarantee your defeat and the whole
point of this was like hey how are we
going to move think
maneuver in a way that a smaller force
that looks weak on paper
and just outmaneuver these big giant
forces because they're inflexible
immobile they're dug in
so that theoretically in my mind
resonated with all sorts of stuff can
you imagine as i was learning jujitsu
and thinking about that actual thing how
many
how many thi how many elements started
to just
come into view like come out of the fog
as i'm thinking through that very thing
i'm learning jiu-jitsu i'm like oh if i
can maneuver myself
over here and put all my force against
a smaller portion of their strength i
can win
all right so he
he goes into the british army
he is part of the king's own yorkshire
light infantry
shout out to yorkshire
he spent time on the western front world
war one uh
got sent back from the front two times
because he was blown up and had
concussive injuries
cool hey listen you you went to the
front you got blown up so bad that you
got sent back because you had concussive
injuries cool you good okay go back
all right you get blown up again boom
you
know what you're good okay go back again
third time he goes back
cool um gets back just in time for the
battle of psalm
and during the battle of the psalm
wounded three times
continued to fight finally he gets
gassed badly enough that he can't
continue fighting
his battalion was just about wiped out
on the first day
of the offensive battle of psalm this so
his battalion was some of the 60 000
casualties on day one
and that event and those events
clearly left a mark on his mentality
because you've heard me go off and talk
about
the i don't know if i've used the word
stupidity before
because it's not the right word but the
the the problem with world war one of
hey okay we just lost a battalion at
zero six hundred cool zero six oh five
dave your battalion is going
okay dave's battalion just got wiped out
okay echo it's 610 your battalion go
and that's what we're doing that left a
mark on him
uh eventually after he's wounded started
to heal up went back
trained new recruits wrote the
infantry training manual after the war
after so then after the war he ends up
writing the infantry training manual
he got married got married to a woman
named jesse stone
we're wondering what layers are there
had a son he retired in 1927 became a
journalist
a military historian military theorist
wrote the most wrote
so much it's ridiculous so much it's
just writing all the time deep
historical writing
analysis worked for prime minister
chamberlain
and he was he was kind of maneuvering in
and getting people to think in a
different way a different way of using
air power or different way of using tank
power a different way of using maneuver
warfare
and of course we all know what happened
with prime minister chamberlain he
was weak and churchill took over
and when churchill took over they kind
of used the
more traditional war strategy in the
beginning
guess who didn't do that you know who
didn't do that hitler the nazis who were
actually paying attention
now there's some question around
how much influence
hart liddell heart had over the nazis
there's definitely some
meaning they were reading you know the
line in in uh patton i read your book
right so patton's saying he read
rommel's book well
there's there are actual connections
between
rommel and some of the other
um more known more well-known and some
of the lesser well-known nazi
leaders that were reading his stuff and
be like this makes this makes sense
there's also a lot of people that will
say that that
b.h liddell heart kind of inflated that
a little bit
but there was some influence
and also regardless of how much of a
connection there was even if there
wasn't a connection
they were both thinking the same things
right they were both taken learning the
same lessons right
uh which that's what that happens
sometimes you know you put somebody in
one situation
they're in a vacuum from someone else if
you put them in a similar situation like
world war one there's a pretty good
chance that they could come to similar
conclusions like
maybe it's not smart just to line up and
start attacking all at once maybe we
should use some decentralized command
maybe we should use maneuver warfare
so they all kind of came to the same
conclusions meaning bh liddell hart
meaning
some of the german and nazi leadership
and so that stuff kind of came into play
so he wrote a bunch of this stuff down
um
he wrote a book called the strategy of
the indirect
approach which was also printed
as the way to win wars which is pretty
cool and what this is kind of what
kicked me
into hyper drive of doing this and we
talked about this on the underground
so i did a post about about the civil
war i didn't post a social media post
about the civil war
about the battle at chancellorville
about jackson taking the indirect path
going 14 miles around to the flank of
the union troops
and winning the battle in an hour as
opposed to just taking the direct
assault
towards the union troops which is a half
a mile and and some of the comments in
there
you know were of course what do i focus
on but most of the comments were like
yeah that makes sense use the indirect
approach
and i talked about using it towards
people and in a leadership position how
the indirect approach is normally the
best way to go
and people were like you know you should
just tell the truth like are you saying
you should lie to people so it was that
whole thing
and so i look i i know where i got these
ideas from
it's no mystery to me and part of it is
the fact that
you put me in and you put someone in an
environment and you make them figure
something out they're going to come to
the same conclusions
right so some of this stuff i was
thinking
man going to the flank makes a lot of
sense and it makes a lot of sense from
leadership
but but i also know that these ideas
were dripped into my head
over the years i mean when you do a
basic seal assault on a target
guess what you set up a base element
that puts down covering fire and then a
flanking element goes around that's what
you do this is not
it's not rocket science so i know that
some of my indirect
my theory my thoughts around in the
indirect strategy the indirect approach
i know some of those
were just from being in the military but
i also know that some of it came from
reading heart and so it made me crack
open some of these books again
and made me kind of fast forward in my
mind
to getting to these sooner in this
podcast
um because
let's face it when
well the theory is based in reality
right and that's what that's what's
interesting about this when you have
someone that spend time in the military
because
the the the name of this book that one
of the books we're going to look at
today is
is the strategy of indirect approach and
it's about the theory
right but if you have someone
when you have someone that's been in war
and spent time as a military leader
and spent time in combat and spent time
in the worst kind of combat
like the actual worst combat
the actual worst combat battle the song
like the worst combat
actual worst combat it's it doesn't it's
not theory anymore
right that theory becomes based deeply
in reality
and that's what we have with
with this book and we'll be covering two
of his books today
um or at least trying to cover two of
them we might make it through i don't
even know how much
because there's a lot to talk about one
is called the strategy of the indirect
approach
which which like i said was also
reprinted as the way to win wars and the
other one's just called strategy
straight up
so i guess we're gonna get to it
anything dave
i wrote down the word travesty when you
were talking about world war one
i just wrote that word down just to
remind me of the thing that i think
about is
you you when you talk about losing a
battalion it's a that's a scale that i
think is actually kind of hard to
comprehend
when you think of a battalion i mean i
have we have lost i've been on patrols
where we lost a vehicle
i lost people in a whole vehicle a
battalion is on a scale and just sort of
the willingness
the willingness to allow that to happen
over and over again and then then
in retrospect thinking and i was
thinking of this as you said it was
the germans had to learn that same
lesson they had to have learned the same
lesson
you know the marine corps takes a little
bit of pride in sort of showing up
having the similar experience and then
saying
we're we're not doing this anymore
really takes pride in that
and we teach that history but in actual
world war one is what you're talking
about yes in actual order 101
of showing up sort of after the war had
been underway for quite some time
getting on board with how is how it was
do uh being done and then
suffering massive casualties in the very
initial engagements and saying
we're done with this direct assault
approach and
the larger point to that is the idea
that
not just for him but for germany as well
the the idea that the way we did that
was a travesty and that that that you
would see how those lessons apply to
well beyond just warfare that that would
sink into your psyche and every single
everything you did in your life would be
informed as such a bad way to describe
like its
influence on a level that you wouldn't
just rethink how you did war
you would rethink every aspect of your
life if you suffered the casualties to
that degree
because of the willingness for leaders
to just say just like you described your
battalion's gone you're up next
and the fact that it influenced every
aspect of his life is actually not even
remotely surprised to me
yeah and it boils down to it and i know
you like when i say this dave
it it becomes not just a theory not just
a strategy but
a way of thinking a way of thinking is
what it becomes
and what's interesting is we're about to
hear exactly
how that transpired in his head
and this is something we covered this we
actually covered this on the underground
but i just
i i had to touch on it on the
underground but we're going to go deep
so here we go here's the preface my
original strat
my original study of the strategy of
indirect approach was written in 1929
published under the title the decisive
wars of history
it has been out of print for some time
so there's another third title that this
book has been
published under in the following year in
the years following its publication i
continued to explore
this line of thought and from the
results of such further study compiled a
number of supplementary
notes which were privately circulated
since the course of the present war has
provided further examples
of the value of the indirect approach
and thereby given
fresh point to the thesis the issue
of a new edition of the book provides an
opportunity
to include these
so now he's writing this he's putting
this one out in
world war ii and actually it's towards
the end of world war ii because
well he's he ends up talking about world
war ii and what's happening
when in the course of studying a long
series of military campaigns
i first came to perceive the superiority
of the indirect
over the direct approach i was looking
merely
for light upon strategy so he starts off
just looking like okay
wait how does this work how can we win
seems like this indirect thing is pretty
cool
it seems like a good strategy for the
battlefield
with deepening reflection however i
began to realize
that the indirect approach had a much
wider application
that it was a law of life in all
spheres a truth of philosophy
[Laughter]
right a law of life in all spheres
so this is where we get crazy because
there's so many people
so many people this like oh you you got
to be direct like that's just such a
common theme
in the world hey you got to be direct
you got to be frank you got to
so so i get it i get it
i get it he found that this has a much
wider application
and it's a law of all all a lot of life
in all spheres a truth of philosophy
its fulfillment was seen to be the key
practical achievement in dealing with
any problem where the human factor
predominates
and a conflict of wills tends to spring
from an underlying concern for interests
okay so here's where this gets awesome
so he's talking about conflict right a
conflict of wills
and what we might fail to realize is
that if i'm on the same team as dave
we can also still have a conflict
of wills because dave wants to do a and
i want to do b
so even though we're on the same team
that's like one of the other
perspectives
that i think about this you know what i
said about leadership capital and
relationships
that's this applies 100 there too
in all such cases in all
such cases so this is cases that where
you have
the human factor anytime you've got the
human factor in all such cases
the direct assault of new ideas
provokes a stubborn resistance thus
intensifying the difficulty
of producing a change of outlook dave
how long have you
how many times have you heard me tell
this to clients
to people this is it
it's i don't have the vocabulary to
explain how often
we say that in some version of that
sentence
in everything but i got to be careful
because i could probably
just it's just hearing it it invokes so
many things to think about but
he's almost articulating it like
when there's a human component to this
and i'm thinking to myself
so when is that not when in my life am i
not interacting with another human being
if we're
if we're doing uh computer software
design
right we don't need to worry about this
right if we're we're actually
programming a machine
of some kind we don't need to worry
about it yeah other than that
other than that if you directly assault
an idea
it's going to provoke stubborn
resistance so if i impose my plan on
dave
it's going to get resistance even though
dave's on my team i impose a plan on him
it's going to be resisted
and it's going to make the change of
outlook harder
it's going to make the change of outlook
harder so if my wife wants something
and i attack it it's going to be
harder for her to change her mind
there's going to be more resistance for
her changing her mind on where we're
going out for dinner
that's what's going to happen
back to the book conversion is achieved
more
easily and rapidly by
unsuspected infiltration of a different
idea
or by an argument that turns the flank
of instinctive opposition
so you're going to get more easy
more easily and more rapidly conversion
of their brain
will come when you flank them
check and faster
and faster rapidly and more easily
by an unsuspected infiltration of a
different idea
and by the way don't let well we'll get
to it so so there's some people that are
thinking right now oh so what you're
gonna do is you're gonna lie to dave
no i'm not gonna lie to dave doesn't
mean i lie doesn't mean i say well
actually dave we should
use my plan because and i'm gonna make
up some intel that supports my plan
i'm gonna make up a timeline that
supports my plan no that's not what i'm
talking about
at all
back to the book in commerce the
suggestion that there is a bargain to be
secured is far
more potent than any direct appeal to
buy
and in any sphere it is a proverbial
that the surest way of gaining a
superior's
acceptance of a new idea is to persuade
him that it is his idea
hello this is something um
again i maybe i should just start paying
uh what is it
paying royalties i just owe royalties to
because
leadership strategy and taxes oh that's
just all in there let us make it their
idea as in war
the aim is to weaken resistance before
attempting to overcome it
and the effect is best attained by
drawing the other party out of his
defenses
great we're not attacking hardened
positions
this idea of the indirect approach is
closely related to
all problems of the influence of mind
upon mind
[Laughter]
all problems of the influence of mind
upon mind
all problems any times it's my mind
against someone else's mind this is
where we need to go indirect
the most influential factor in human
history
yet it is hard to reconcile with another
lesson
that true conclusions can only be
reached or approached by pursuing the
truth without regard to where it may
lead
or what its effect may be on different
interests
so what do we say in there now he's
saying wait a second wait a second what
shouldn't we be going after the truth
like isn't it
look if i'm working with dave and i
think my plan is better
well then i need to tell him that that's
the truth the truth is my plan's better
and what's so hard about this this is
one of those universal things that
pisses me off
i got you is
there's no one that
it's it's a it's it's against all
uh moral high ground
to lie right so the opposite of lying
is what truth telling the truth so
if we're starting to think that this is
not telling the truth then what are we
doing
we must be lying
so how do so how do we reconcile that's
what we're saying how do we reconcile
this wait
i have a different plan than dave i
think my plan's better
i should tell them the truth that's what
i should do
i shouldn't lie to him we're not talking
about lying to him
back to the book history bears witness
to the vital part
that the prophets have played in human
progress
which is evidence of the ultimate
practical value
of expressing unreservedly the truth as
one sees it
okay so now we're gonna get he's gonna
use the example historical examples and
there's countless
of prophets
someone that is a prophet that stands up
and says
this is the truth as i see it and tells
the truth
yet it also becomes clear that the
acceptance and spreading of their vision
has always depended on another class of
men
what's the other class of men leaders
leaders who had to be philosophical
strategists
striking a compromise between truth
and men's receptivity to it
so lately i've been saying a lot of what
good is telling the truth if no one
hears it or no one listens to you
you if you if you stab somebody in the
eye with the dagger of truth
what are they gonna do they're gonna be
pissed they're gonna they're gonna lash
out at you they might even
you know pull out a sidearm and shoot
you in the gut
but they definitely don't want to hear
anything from it and they'll do their
best to
pull that thing back out and stab you
with it so you even made any progress at
all
so that's what a prophet does a prophet
says this is the truth and they stab you
in the eye with it
a leader has to find that compromise
between telling the truth and getting
people to actually listen to it
their effect has often depended as much
on their own limitations in perceiving
the truth
as on their practical wisdom in
proclaiming it so how are you going to
tell the truth
practical wisdom how are you going to
what are you going to say how are you
going to say it where it will actually
be
listen to and then he goes on to say
this
the prophets must be stoned
that is their lot that is their test of
their self-fulfillment
right what happens to the prophet the
prophet gets stolen the prophet gets
crucified
that's what happens
but a leader who is stoned may merely
prove
that he has failed in his function
through a deficiency of wisdom or
through confusing his
function with that of a prophet this is
pure brilliance by the way
this is absolute pure brilliance so
if you're that if you're in a leadership
position and what you do is you start
stabbing people
with the dagger of truth in the neck
and you think you're doing a good thing
guess what they're going to
tackle you and they're going to stone
you to death they're going to execute
you because you were stabbing people and
it offended them and it hurt them
and that you didn't convince anybody of
anything
so sometimes you get a leader that's
like oh look the truth is
listen dave i gotta tell you the truth
here that's not good
it's not gonna help you
dude it's crazy you're like on page one
i know
page one half yeah
i think the the phrase that's been
coming to mind a lot
lately when you talk about this is is
a truth that it's imposed upon somebody
compared to the truth that they discover
for themselves the difference between
those two
and i'm thinking of all the like the
phrases that people use when they're
going to reveal the truth
let me stop you right there actually
like
and when you hear people prepping for
the the direct assault which is
i'm now going to let you know and even
the preparation for that
just that phrase alone puts the other
person in a position where all they want
to do
is defend themselves and the words that
come next
almost don't even matter because if i
say actually
jocko the reality is the reality is
the first thing you do is is you
mentally you are dug in
no matter how truthful i'm going to be
after that it's just the connection he's
making though
like the how universal that is to all
interactions is just
it's it's crazy listening to this and
then the
the application to every interaction you
have
like with every with any human being and
how instinctive it is to
i guess tell the truth and how
ineffective
that way of thinking is if there's an
outcome that you're trying to shape
um echo charles yes sir have you ever
seen
the movie raiders of the lost ark yes
sir
okay so there's an ark right the ark
of the covenant and i think the truth is
kind of like that
if you reveal that truth in an improper
way
people's faces are melting oh yeah
that's what happens
yeah so people people treat the truth
as if it's only benevolent as if it can
only do good
yeah but you got to remember there's
collateral that truth causes collateral
damage and people don't pay attention to
that
so when you start pulling off the lid
maybe you got to like
you got to prep people for it you got to
say hey turn your eyes for a second here
there's going to be some bright lights
if you don't prep them for and what what
we want to do
what we want to do is we want them to
reveal the truth to themselves that's
what we really want
a really good leader look a prophet will
show you the truth maybe you're getting
melted
a really good leader you somehow
discover the truth
i mean they showed it to you but you
don't even know it so the whole
expression
the truth hurts you know that that's
because that's kind of common right
so would that be an indicator of maybe a
profit or
or at the time at least not the correct
that's profit all day long
profit is like look echo truth hurts but
i'm going to tell you something
you know what i mean how how sus how
open-minded are you when i get done with
that statement
oh i would meet it with stubborn
resistance check
and you know we like to think that well
you know i really have a good
relationship with some you know
great there might be one person in your
entire life
that you can be like hey dude that was
jacked up and you're like cool
got it what adjustments do i need
there's one person in your life you can
do that with
yeah maybe isn't that at the end of the
day in a way the indirect approach
anyway because you know you say okay
that one person yeah but you know why
is that one person because you have this
years and years and years and years and
years of this indirect you know
kind of approach or whatever and then
yeah so you open up that little hole
that yeah you have that direct line
all day now yeah now exactly yes you are
correct
even that approach because if you would
have met that person day one
three years ago and said you know i was
looking at that video you made
i'm not feeling it actually you know the
camera angles that you use
kind of marginal right
[Music]
with you before i could be like bruh the
soundtrack
no actually you put a christmas song in
there it was actually right away
uh back to the book time alone can tell
whether the effect of such a sacrifice
redeems the apparent failure as a leader
that does honor to him as a man so
there's a chance that you could
you could present something in over time
people go yeah he was right
at the least he avoids the more common
fault of leader
of leaders that of sacrificing the truth
to expediency without ultimate advantage
to the cause
so occasionally a leader is like you
know what
we just need to tell the truth and you
sacrifice it it gets killed it gets
thrown away
and then one of the books that i'm or
the podcast that i want to move to from
this one which i will get to and i'm not
100 sure when but
they got all these examples of problems
in in the military and military thinking
and one of the problems and i forget the
exact number but there's been like
20 major advancements in naval
warfare in the last 500 years
and every one of them was met with
absolutely stiff resistance no not
everyone
17 of them were met with stiff
resistance by
all senior naval leaders in the world
you know they started making ships uh
from steel instead of what a bunch of
like this is griot you can't repair
steel we can eat a welder like they
resisted
uh switching to the steam engine
switching to gas
whichever diesel switching to like all
the every people resisted
every one of these things every one of
them well sorry 17 out of 20.
of great advancements it happens all the
time
because somebody goes hard with the
truth
and people defend they go on instant
defense mode
so like remember the movie uh
independence
no no armageddon i don't think i ever
actually saw it but
stupid it's good flick i'm sure it's i
wasn't up for several oscars
anyway armageddon bruce willis oh yeah
uh asteroid coming in right what was the
what was the plan that wanna do you
watch armageddon deeper
sorry dude bro independence
it's okay i'll explain to you asteroid
coming in right world uh world ending
asteroid global killer so they're like
hey let's just throw uh
blast it with nukes and blow it right
out of the sky then the smart scientist
is like that's a bad idea everyone gets
all mad right no that's it we're gonna
eat a direct approach
lunch nukes right can't get any more
direct than that
but the smart scientist said nope this
is what you're going to do you're going
to go in there you're going to drill a
little hole
you're going to put a nuke in that hole
you're going to just nudge it just a
little bit from the side
so now the trajectory the trajectory
gets changed
you see insane that was the smarter
approach same thing yeah exactly right
right
here i am going through historical books
trying to figure this stuff out and i
couldn't figure it out with uh
armageddon bruce willis yeah you don't
gotta bother with all this
check back to the book
we good yes armageddon yeah i'm just
saying these ideas are everywhere
we go man uh for whoever habitually
suppresses the truth so this is this is
where this is where you have to pay
attention
because again it's not me lying to dave
and saying well actually dave
uh the timeline that's required for the
plan you but we better use my plan
whoever habitually suppresses the truth
in the interest of tact
will produce a deformity from the womb
of this thought
so you can't you can't lie about what
you're saying
you have to maintain you have to
maintain the truth
but you have to take an indirect
approach that's it
it's not a lie it's an indirect approach
bound to the truth
he explains it a little bit more is
there a practical way of combining
progress towards the attainment of truth
with progress towards its acceptance so
is there a way to get dave to
think about my plan and utilize my plan
with also doing it in a way that he is
open to accept this idea
is there a combination of those two
things of telling dave the truth about
what i think of his plan
and at the same time getting him to
accept my opinion that's what we want
right
a possible solution of the problem is
suggested by reflection on strategic
principles
which point to the importance of
maintaining an object
consistently and also of pursuing it in
a way
adapted to the circumstances
this seems so obvious is that we we
we continue to focus on the right thing
but then we continue to move towards
this objective
but as circumstances change we adjust we
adjust we maneuver
we say oh yeah there's a massive enemy
uh
location right here let's not continue
in that direction let's go around it
isn't it smart to do that with our ideas
as well it doesn't mean we abandon the
objective it doesn't mean we we say oh
we're going to change this objective or
we're not going to continue towards it
means we adjust
our approach and maybe instead of going
direct
we go indirect
opposition to the truth is inevitable
that's a good thing to remember
especially if it takes the form of a new
idea
but the degree of resistance can be
diminished
by giving thought not only to the aim
but to the method of approach
avoid a frontal attack in a long
established position
instead seek to turn it by a flank
movement
so that the more penetrable side is
exposed
to the thrust of the truth
but in any such indirect approach take
care
not to diverge from the truth for
nothing is more
fatal to its real advancement than to
lapse
into the untruth
so for the people that commented when i
talked about the indirect approach and
were like
oh so you're just gonna lie to your
people no
no we're not gonna lie to our people the
truth is the objective
but we are going to adjust our approach
so that we're not
offensive to the individuals or the
groups that we're talking to
so that we don't cause them to put up a
more stiff resistance to fight against
our idea
to to for them to look at it as if it's
not the truth
we're gonna we're gonna flank that's
what we're gonna do
and then he goes on here and he says the
meaning of these reflections
may be made clearer by illustration from
one's own experience
looking back on the stages
by which various fresh ideas gained
acceptance it can be seen
that the process was eased when they
could be presented not as something
radically new but as a revival in modern
terms of a time-honored principle or
practice that had been forgotten so
here's his one of his little indirect
approaches is to take a new idea
and and and camouflage it
with an old idea it's kind of like what
the what the christians did with the
vikings
right easter you know where you know the
term easter sure
and yeah it's it's a it's a pagan thing
but we call it's a pagan word and it's a
pagan ceremony
but the christians are like oh yeah you
can call the thing in the spring
we call that easter it's cool it's about
christ rising but you know we call it
easter
it's sort of a thing that you guys
already do they just kind of take an old
idea and re-brand it that's
actually what they did yeah i think they
did that with christmas
did that with christmas too so that's
what we're doing we're kind of
camouflaging this idea so it's a little
more open to it hey you know how you
guys do the
the springtime thing and you guys
celebrate birth
right we we had you know like a rebirth
kind of co-brand that thing we're good
it's kind of like your dog right when
you feed them the heart pills
right heartworm pills okay you put it
yeah yeah put a little
put a little uh piece of steak around
that thing yeah you know like you've
been eating this food this whole time
yeah yeah yeah just put the put the
heartworm pills in there
he goes he goes on to say here this
required not deception but care to trace
the connection since there
is nothing new in the sun right you can
always figure out something that ties
into what you're doing
a notable example was the way that op
the opposition to mechanized
mechanization was diminished by showing
that the mobile armored
vehicle the fast-moving tank was
fundamentally the heir of the armored
horseman
and thus the natural means of reviving
the decisive role which
cavalry played in past ages
which is what we call what do we call
armored cavalry now
why is that because people resist this
tank it's going to get stuck it takes
gas
i mean a horse can go forever you can
eat off the land how are you going to
refuel these tanks people just resisted
that idea resist
and then it's like oh no no this is the
new cavalry oh okay kind of cool then
we're down
so what can you do as you try and
convince people of ideas
take an old idea repackage it and it's
true
because there's no new ideas under the
sun it's not like you're lying to them
i i don't know obviously what's coming
uh in terms of
you know the how much detail is in and
what we're going to discuss but even
just
even just the word the truth how that's
the the it's the topic that you're
trying to get across
yes and even what what that means like
if i have an idea that's different than
me like trying to get you to understand
some sort of like hey two plus two is
four
and you're gonna say no okay as opposed
to i think we should do this
and the abandonment of of that truth
versus
all right listen i can't just walk up to
jock and go hey this is how we're gonna
this is the new way we're going to do is
solve this problem and even just the
word truth
has a connotation like i'm right and
you're wrong as opposed to
hey i'm trying to get you to see this a
different way and it might not end up
exactly how i've drawn it out maybe my
drawing is like
ends up in 80 or whatever but
i could see people getting hung up the
idea that i have to convince jocko of
the truth
meaning i know the answer and he doesn't
and if he doesn't then i've got to
figure out how to and maybe the fast way
to
just shove it in his face and go dude
this is what we're doing as opposed to
getting him to see that there might be
another way of doing it which is
actually the truth
as opposed to it has to be exactly my
way and if there's a minefield between
you and me
i i guess i could go into that minefield
but
it's not going to help me get you to see
something different and
he i think said the quote is resistance
to the truth
is inevitable yep resistance to your
ideas are
inevitable so let's not let's not
pretend like you might be able to
avoid that resistance that minefield
that that barrier that wall
it is there i just think the idea of the
truth
of us committing to it is this way as
opposed to i want to think of something
a different way yeah no that's a great
point because
what we're really well when we start
talking about it in a leadership
capacity it becomes hey it's
my idea yeah and as we were talking on
ef online today
it's like my assumption is that my idea
is flawed right
and i can present my idea to you but i i
still
present it as if not it's the truth
but it's an idea of a possibility
now what's interesting is what does that
do to my idea it makes it indirect
totally it makes it indirect me
packaging the idea that i have
as a possibility or as a thought or an
idea for me as opposed
to this is the way we should do it it
makes it an indirect approach
and what we talked about today
on ef online
i actually believe that so i don't have
to like act i don't have to pretend like
hey
i'm gonna pretend like this isn't the
best idea ever and like dave should just
shut up and do it my way i'm gonna i'm
gonna pretend that
so that way it's a little more indirect
no i actually think you know what this
is
my idea seems like a good idea but there
could be some holes pumped into it which
is which is fine
i'm okay with that so yeah when we start
talking about
getting people's ideas and anytime you
i mean there's very few things that i
actually here's something i've said
early podcasts
is the amount of times that i say dave
bro listen this is what we should do
yeah
the only reason i'm going to say that is
if i am 100 percent
100 percent convicted that i and
it you probably have never even heard me
say that
because it's so rare now look there was
times where in the seal team somebody
wanted to do something that was
bad oh you wanna you wanna set up on two
sides of a road and ambush someone in
the middle
okay so that means we're gonna be
shooting at each other like this is bad
we do not wanna do that of course how
often did guys present a plan to me like
that
almost never so most of the time it was
you know hey
think through that but very rarely
very rarely do i have the approach that
i actually know the capital t
truth right so this is a very good
point to make you you whoever you are
you don't know the truth very seldom are
you 100
convinced hey my idea is the truth
don't walk around with that attitude
it's not good
all right we're getting into this next
section here
which is called history as practical
experience starts off by saying
fools say that they learn by experience
i prefer
to profit by others experience this
famous saying quoted by bismarck
but by no means original to him has
peculiar bearing on military questions
for it has often been remarked that the
soldier unlike followers of other
professions has but rare opportunities
to practice his profession isn't that
interesting look you're in the military
cool
you're a professional soldier awesome
how often do you
actually get to do that job the answer
is
not as often as a normal not as often as
a carpenter
not as often as a plumber not as often
as a software engineer
you might get to train for it you might
but how often are you
locked and loaded and in combat with
someone else in the military
back to the book indeed it might even be
argued that in a literal sense the
profession of arms is not a profession
at all but merely
casual employment and paradoxically that
it ceased to be a profession when the
soldier of fortune gave way to the
professional soldier when mercenary
troops who were employed and paid for
the purpose of war
were replaced by standing armies which
continued to be paid when there was no
war so if you're a mercenary you'd be
like oh there's a war over there cool
i'm gonna go do it that's kind of like a
plumber oh there's a different one over
here cool i'm gonna go to that one oh
there's a different world over here
coleman
that's a little bit more of an actual
profession you might end up in more
combat in your life than if you're
in a standing army that's doing that job
even when there's no war going on this
logical if somewhat extreme argument
recalls
the excuse often made in the past for
paying officers a rate inadequate to
live on
and by some of those officers for doing
an inadequate day's work
the contention being that the officer's
pay was not
a working salary but a retainer paid to
him for the benefit
of having his services available in case
of war
this reminds me of some of the some of
the information about
the the british army and how just
the officers during certain phases
were just actual aristocrats
that had almost no interest in fighting
wars
and almost complete interest in going to
the country club
some of the um some of the
biographies of some of the guys that led
the boor war
were pretty embarrassing
and then they showed up for the boomer
war with
pianos and just it's like crazy
if the argument that strictly there is
no profession of arms will not hold
good in most armies today on the score
of work
it is inevitably strengthened on a s the
score of practice by the increasing for
infrequency of wars so there's less and
less wars now
are we then left with the conclusion
that armies are doomed to become more
and more amateurish in the popular bad
sense
of that much abused and misused word so
hey look if you're in the military
you're not getting a fight all the time
does that mean you become an amateur
over time
for obviously even the best of peace
training is more theoretical
than practical and experience and you
know what i like well the reason i
wasn't going to do this section
but guess what it's the same thing with
leadership it's the same thing with
leadership you're in a leadership
position
how often are you actually in a
challenging situation
in leadership how often does someone say
hey boss i'm not doing this how often
does someone say
that i'm not working with that person
like you you end up with combative
situations
but how often is that because normally
people are hey yeah yeah got it boss
hope that sounds like a good plan like
that's what you're normally getting
you're not normally as a leader
hopefully you're not normally being
combative
so it's the same thing how do we train
for that
bismarck throws a different and more
encouraging encouraging light on the
problem it helps us to realize that
there are two forms of practical
experience direct and indirect
and that of the two indirect practical
experience may be more valuable
because it's infinitely wider so look
you can get that experience of dealing
with a bad employee but how often
do you actually deal with i mean how
many marines did you have to write up
hardly any yeah ever i mean like how
many
seals did i have to write up how many
seals did i have to fire
when we're working with companies we
were with companies with thousands of
employees
the combative situations are
much more rare than the day-to-day hey
this is what we're doing
normal leadership yeah and how often is
the problem
even as bad as you think it is you know
when we'll get questions about
hey how do i deal with a boss who um you
know wants my team to fail
when i say hey if you really think about
the problem they're not they're often
not as bad or as significant
and not of the magnitude that we even
make it out to be
right even in the most active career
especially a soldier's career the scope
and possibilities of direct experience
are
extremely limited in contrast to the
military the medical profession has
incest in practice right they're doing a
surgery a day two surgeries a day three
surgeries a day
yet the great achievements in medicine
and surgery have usually been due to the
research
worker and not to the general
practitioner direct experience is
inherently too limited a form
to form a secure foundation for either
theory or application so if the only
combat experience you're gonna get is
combat experience you're you're going to
be you're going to be screwed
at the best it produces an atmosphere
which is value
in drying and hardening the structure of
our thought
if you only have a little bit of combat
experience that's what you become if you
don't open your mind up
if you only have a little bit of
leadership experience that's what
happens when you get
in the seal teams you know we'd have the
on the job training leadership that's
how guys would become
that's how they get their leadership
training just by watching their platoon
chief for their platoon commander
so if they weren't good that
bad example would dry and harden in
their mind and become the way they would
be too because they didn't open their
mind up to different
indirect experience the greater value of
indirect experience lies in its
greater variety and extent right
history is universal experience the
experience not of another but of many
others
under manifold conditions boom
so we can learn about leadership from
everywhere
here we have the rational justification
for military history
it's preponderant practical value in the
training
and mental development of a soldier but
but the benefit depends as with all
experience on its breadth on how closely
it approaches the definition quoted
above
and on the method of studying it so we
got to study and
look the whole premise of this
particular podcast
is understanding human nature is
understanding leadership by
understanding how people act in war
why is that why don't we study a bunch
of business cases well
because if you want to see
human nature be revealed you got to put
some pressure on it
you got to put some bread there's no
better pressure
no better pressure than combat soldiers
universally concede
the general truth of napoleon's
much-quoted dictum that in war
the moral is to the physical as three to
one
cool we covered that on this podcast
and all of napoleon's maxims but here we
go the actual arithmet
arithmetic proportion may be worthless
for morale's app to decline if weapons
be inadequate
and the strongest will is a vet little
use inside of a dead body
but although the moral and physical
factors are inseparable and
indivisible the saying gains its
immortal value because it expresses the
idea of the predominance the
predominance
of moral factors in all military
decisions
so obviously it's not like okay here's
the numerical
you have this much you have this much
physical situation oh don't worry
morale's three to one that's not what
we're talking about
but it's that idea on them constantly
turns the issue
of worn battle and in history of war
they form
the more constant factors changing only
in degree whereas physical factors are
fundamentally different in almost every
war in every military situation
that's the important part of this
you've got the you've got the physical
factors right the physical
but that changes but what doesn't change
the history of war they form more
constant factors to green
changing only in degree the physical
factors go all over the place
because we got machine guns we got tanks
we got people with night vision like
it's there's different
physical things but the but the human
nature doesn't change
this realization affects the whole
question of the study of military
history history for practical use
the the method in the last few
generations has been to select one or
two campaigns and to study them
exhaustively
as means of developing both our minds
and a theory of war
but the continual changes in military
means from war to war
entail a grave danger even a certainty
that our outlook will be narrow and and
lessens
fallacious in the physical sphere
the one constant factor is that means
and condition
are invariably inconsistent so so the
physical stuff we can study it like okay
would
how did you maneuver in this situation
how did you
how did what weapons did you use over
here well guess what you fast forward 30
years and we got different weapons
you fast forward six years and we go
from no night vision to all night vision
so if that's what we're studying what
are we looking at
in contrast human nature varies but
slightly in its reaction to danger
some men by race by environment or by
training may be less sensitive than
others but the difference
is one of degree not fundamental so
people are people
the more localized the situation and our
study the more disconcerting and less
calculable
is such a difference of degree it may
prevent an exact calculation of the
resistance which men will offer in any
situation but it does not impair
the judgment that they will offer less
if taken by surprise than if they are on
alert
this is like so it doesn't matter where
you look in history the
person that's surprised versus the
person that's on alert you're going to
get the same
almost the exact same reaction less if
they are weary and hungry than if
they're fresh and well fed look we
go back thousand years 2 000 years
well-fed troops that are well-rested are
ready to rock and roll
weary hungry they're not
the broader the the broader the
psychological
survey the better foundation it affords
for deductions so you have to look
throughout
history and see all these different
battles and see what the psychology of
the soldiers and leaders was
the predominance of the psychological
over the physical
and its greater consistency point
to the conclusion that the foundation of
any theory of war should be as broad as
possible
an intensive study of one campaign
unless based upon
unless based on extensive knowledge of
the whole history of war
is as likely to lead us into pitfalls as
onto the peaks of military achievement
so if you just look at one campaign and
that's where you base everything on
you're wrong
but if a certain effect is seen to
follow a certain cause in a
score or more cases in different epochs
and diverse conditions
there is ground for regarding this cause
as an integral part of any theory of war
you see something one time it doesn't
mean jack
if you see something four times but it's
all in the same campaign and the same
locale and the same
soldiers fighting against the same other
soldiers again it's a minimal
but when you take it over centuries or
millennia
and you see the same thing over and over
again
maybe you should pay attention to that
one
the thesis set force in this book is the
product of such an extensive examination
it might indeed
be termed the compound effect of certain
causes these being connected with
my task of military editor for
encyclopedia or britannica
that's kind of crazy for while i had
previously delved into various periods
of military history
according to my inclination this task
compelled a general general survey of
all off and against my
uh inclination so he was the military
editor for the encyclopedia encyclopedia
britannica you know what that is echo
charles of course yes
well i'm just saying are you a
millennial no i'm not
taco some people i bet a kid right now
does not know what
the encyclopedia britannica was when we
were kids
that was kind of it right that was
google that was google yeah
yep that was google gotta go find the
letter yes spine yeah on that spine
boom pull it out there you go and there
are some letters that were like two and
one
like q and r all right cool we're good
with that book with that volume
so this guy was the ed the military
editor
and even though previously he would just
kind of study what he wanted to study
but then all of a sudden he had to go
back and study all these other things
and he starts seeing all these
continual similarities
through everything he's seeing and here
we go
um he says and a survey or even a
tourist if you will
has at least a wide perspective and can
at least take
in the general lie of the land where the
miner knows only his seam
so if you if you study one war one
battle and that's when you just go deep
in that scene
hey you know a lot about that one scene
but the guy that's up up at altitude
surveying all land he's got the whole
lay of the land
during this survey one impression grew
ever stronger
that throughout the ages throughout the
ages decisive results in war
have only been reached when the approach
has been indirect
in strategy the longest way round
is apt to be the shortest way home
[Laughter]
more and more clearly has the fact
emerged that a direct approach to one's
mental object or physical objective
and he use he uses this term a lot as as
you're going to hear me read he just
calls something the object
we always call it the objective and he
actually goes into like why that's not a
good word
so a lot of times you'll hear them say
object
um more and more clearly has the fact
emerged that a direct approach to one's
mental object or physical objective
along the line of natural expectation
for the opponent
has ever tended to and usually produce
negative results so if you take that
path
that's kind of expected chances are
we're not gonna we're not gonna it's not
gonna work out well
the reason has been expressed vividly in
napoleon's dictum
that the moral is the physical is three
to one it may be expressed
scientifically by saying that while the
strength of an
enemy country lies outwardly in its
numbers and resources
these are equally dependent upon
stability or equilibrium of control
morale and supply
to move along the line of natural
expectation
consolidates the opponent's equilibrium
and
by stiffening it augments his resisting
power
i think that comment the one you made
just a minute ago
that quote the longest way around is the
shortest way home
i think that's the piece that that for
whatever reason i think we see is the
most
hard to to to accept that
and and i think my point is probably
better served by saying the opposite is
also true the shortest way around is the
longest way home
there's this belief like if i just get
to the point i will get to the end
faster and the opposite is true and just
the
the willingness to recognize the more
indirect i i am the longer this journey
is to get
this other person to see the truth the
faster this is going to be
and that's such a hard thing i think for
people to
embrace for example what you just said
is is
the more you see me taking this direct
path towards you the more
the more dug in you will become because
you see it coming
and what i'm doing is so much less
important than
how i am doing it that you won't hear
any things i'm saying any of the ideas
that i'm offering or any any of the
the truth that i'm delivering and it
will take me longer and the
i'm a direct person i have to tell the
truth that's just how i
am the recognition that that is the
longest the longest way
and and sometimes you'll never get there
yep
yeah the the way i often explain this to
clients
is i i usually just preemptively say i
know what you're all thinking
you all are thinking is that doesn't
sound very efficient it'd be much more
efficient for me just to say dave this
is how we're doing it
be way more efficient to do that and
it's just
like you said it's just so hard to
realize that that's the longest way home
that's the longest way home
the line i just read to move along the
line of natural expectation
that's the shortest route consolidates
the opponent's equilibrium
so when you when you are going where
they expect you to go
that's where they put their defenses
that's what happens
that's why in jiu jitsu you have to mess
with their balance
you have to come from a different angle
and by stiffening by stiffening it
augments its resisting power
by the way because when you know where
i'm coming at you from
you are ready to fight and you know what
to do to fight
in war as in wrestling
the attempt to throw the opponent
without loosening his foothold imbalance
can only result in self-exhaustion
increasing in disproportionate ratio to
the effective strain put upon him
victory by such a method can only be
possible through an immense
margin of superior strength in some form
and even so tends to lose decisiveness
so if we're wrestling
which let's face it we're wrestling if
what we do is
attempt a a takedown with no setup or
attempt a submission with no setup it
doesn't work
it doesn't work like we're training with
kerry today
carrie's a white belt right guess what
he's a wipeout been training for a year
if you grab his arm
you're not gonna get it you're not gonna
get it you have to do something else
you have to set him up even a white belt
in jiu jitsu
in contrast an examination of military
history
not of one period but of its whole
course brings out the point that in
almost
all the decisive campaigns the
dislocation of the enemy's psychological
and physical balance
has been vit the vital prelude to a
successful attempt at his overthrow
dislocation he uses that word a lot
dislocation
putting people off balance getting
getting that
getting in their head not letting them
well i guess it's the true opposite
it's the opposite of consolidation of
equilibrium right like here i am i'm
stable oh
dislocated now i'm not where i i'm not
where i want to be
this dislocation has been produced by a
strategic indirect approach
intentional or fortuitous so sometimes
people just accidentally end up off
balancing somebody cool
it may take varied forms as our analysis
reveals
for the strategy of the indirect
approach is inclusive of
but what and but wider than the
maneuver sir lay derriere
which is french which i don't even want
to try but it means
maneuver behind someone which general
cayman's researches
showed as being the constant aim and key
method of napoleon
in his conduct of operations while
cayman was concerned primarily with the
logistical moves
the factors of time space and
communications this analysis
seeks to probe deeper into psychological
foundations and in doing so
finds an underlying relationship between
many strategical operations
which have no outward resemblance to a
maneuver against the enemy's rear
yet are none less definitely vital
examples of the strategy of the indirect
approach
so sometimes it doesn't look like what
you're doing
is an indirect maneuver but it is
to trace this relationship and determine
the character of operations is not
necessary
and is indeed irrelevant to tabulate the
numerical strengths
and detail the details of supply and
transport
our concern is simply with historical
effects in a comprehensive series of
cases
and with the logistical or psychological
moves which led us
led up to them if similar effects follow
fundamentally
similar moves in conditions which vary
widely in scale
nature and date there's clearly an
underlying connection from which we can
logically deduce a common cause
and the more widely the conditions vary
the firmer this conduction
this deduction and and what he's saying
there is
look when you take a bunch of examples
over time
throughout history it becomes really
clear that this isn't just a fluke this
is the reality of the situation
and that's so so here's what we're gonna
do
um this guy is a historian right
and the next giant chunk of these books
is he goes historical what was that book
we were reading
where people went statistical oh yeah
that's right it was one of those world
war ii thing somebody went statistical
sometimes yeah the officer went
statistical on me started telling me
about how
how long officers were living he's like
the average officer's living about
living about four and a half hours up
there good luck he went statistical on
me
what bh liddell hart does he goes
historical
and he goes from the 5th century to the
20th century he goes from the greek wars
the roman wars the byzantine wars the
medieval wars the 17th century the 18th
century the french revolution napoleon
he gets to the first world war the
second world war
and he goes through just detailed
battles and talks about the indirect
approach
and what we're going to do is we're
actually going to bypass this
and there's a couple reasons why number
one get the books
get the books number two this is what we
do all the time on this podcast
this is actually what we do all the time
on this podcast
we talk about napoleon we talk about his
push into russia
we talk about world war one we talk
about world war ii we talk about vietnam
we talk about korea
and we've seen and pointed out the
indirect strategy all the time
all the time that's what we do we how do
i usually talk about it the flank
right this is this we talked about
maneuver warfare this is what this is
about this is what this whole podcast is
about
is these historical lessons and and ph
ladell
heart he he serves them up
for us in this book
the so so if you want to get those
and who knows maybe one day we'll jump
into these
but if you want to jump into them get
the book get the book strategy by bh
lodell heart you can get
in depth on these things
but what i want to do is i want to kind
of jump ahead to his book strategy where
he goes into
the theory of strategy
and he starts off by saying having drawn
our conclusions from analysis oh by the
way the analysis that he's talking about
that he draws conclusions from is like
315 pages so this is this is no
this is when when he's talking about oh
you need to study all these different
errors he does it
and points out the indirect approach and
how it wins every single time
even if it was by accident it's what
makes us win
he says having drawn our conclusions
from analysis of history it seems
advantageous to construct on the fresh
foundation of a new dwelling house for
the strategic thought
so he's looked at all these things that
have happened and we gotta kind of get
we kind of gotta hit the reset button
he says let us first be clear on what is
strategy
klauswitz in his monumental work
on ward defined it as the art
of the employment of battles as a means
to gain the object of war
in other words strategy comes strategy
forms the plan of war
maps out the proposed course of the
different campaigns
which compose the war and regulates the
battles to be fought in each now this is
probably since episode seven
of this podcast people have been like
hey you need classmates you gonna do
classmates on war hey you gonna do one
war
and there's a couple reasons why i
haven't done it yet and i'm sure we will
and i owe it to military history to do
it
but there's a couple reasons one reason
it's like kind of it's such a popular
one that's like hey you know what that's
right out there
is it really the first one i want to hit
i'd rather hit some
other
strategical ideas i mean i guess i did
do sun tzu on war so this is not this is
more of an excuse maybe
i've always known that klaus wits or i
always felt that klaus wits
you know respect respect crosswitz we're
giving him respect
um by the way here's why this crossfits
is no just hey military theorist right
this is a guy that sat in a
ivory tower and thought about war uh
he entered the military at age 12 as a
lance corporal
you know what i'm saying like this is no
joke uh
fought in the rhine campaigns fought in
the napoleonic wars
went to the military academy at berlin
worked
worked for charnhorst who i've talked
about a bunch on this podcast because
when it comes to maneuver warfare he's
kind of that guy in the beginning that
lost with the prussian army to napoleon
at the battle of jenna
and when he did he looked around said
what the hell just happened and realized
there was some decentralized some
indirect warfare going on and started
kind of making that well well classified
kind of was
under his wing
and then when the prussians made an
alliance with napoleon
klaus was like no and he joined the uh
imperial russian army
and then when they broke up that
alliance he went back to the the
prussian army
it was the chief of staff a three core
and just
battles napoleonic battles
uh at the battle of waterloo he was
he was in that campaign he was
preventing some of napoleon's
reinforcements and showing up
which which obviously caused the problem
went back was an instructor and then the
director of the
of the military academy at berlin
and by the way this whole time he's
writing down what his thoughts are
and then he he ended up dying of cholera
before he had these
before he was able to complete his works
and really before
you might say and lydell hart kind of
makes the assumption that he was kind of
heading in a different direction
so he's cr he's respectful but critical
of koswitz that's kind of that's
i don't say that's the way i've always
felt but i kind of have always felt that
way a little bit
i don't know maybe that's because i'm a
little bit of a contrarian but maybe
more than that
klaus woods says things that i go really
really
and by the way the klaus wits mentality
is kind of
what brought us to world war one and
that mentality of mass which is one of
his primary
premier uh principles
is like hey we're gonna get i have more
people than you
i'm gonna win which as we know when we
compare that to the
the principles behind light infantry
it's not what we're looking for
there's also a connection in there too
even between what was talking about
earlier between the physical and the
moral
of these physical attributes and you
know they vary from campaign to campaign
which is part of the reason why
you don't want to overreact to the
lesson the physical lessons of a
particular campaign because
even as simple as like desert warfare
versus jungle warfare
those lessons forwarding rivers those
are physical lessons and then
it's not that they're invaluable but the
the physical principles
of mass or or those components
are less important now one without the
other you have to have them both
but i was even just sitting here
thinking of when tom fife was here
who's talking about world war ii korea
and vietnam
not from a a um historical standpoint
but from actually a participant
standpoint but the lessons he was
talking about
he didn't spend a bunch of time when
world war ii we were dealing with this
physical environment it was
the universal the universal nature of
his lessons were
take care of your people i mean how many
books have we
have i listened to on this podcast or
read that the
fundamental principle of leadership in
success in battle
was taking care of your people you know
i'm looking at about faces
as i'm looking at hundreds and hundreds
and hundreds of pages and he probably
has a whole bunch of physical lessons
and and it's not to say that those
aren't important but those are never the
ones that the leaders
really when they're talking about the
lessons they learn and that that moral
component i'm just using moral to use
the same language
it's the human nature piece like you
were talking about and how much more
important that is
and i remember even in getting a
master's degree was was klaus was
sort of central to the strategic studies
and there's a physical
focus on that and the principle of mass
is a great example
and listen
i would love to go to war with an
advantage in mass every time i that's a
that'd be awesome
but but we know that that's not the
deciding factor we know that
interestingly as you pointed to about
face um there's one book
that we haven't covered on this podcast
by colonel david hackworth
which you would think would be just like
prime it's called vietnam vietnam primer
and vietnam primer is a book to get you
ready to go to vietnam and it literally
shows like hey here's how far out you
should put your claymores on
it's it's just we could cover it i'm
sure we could
we could get some lessons from it but
compared to about face
not even close here's the other thing
that's interesting is that cover move
right cover and move
the first law of combat leadership
if you're in the jungle you better cover
and move if you're in the desert you
better cover move
if you're doing a river crossing you
better cover and move
if you're doing an assault you better
cover and move if you're in an airplane
if you're in an airplane at 38 000 feet
ac kicking yeah you better cover and
move
so that's i think what was weird for me
was as
like cover move and that's another thing
cover and move
cover and move movement
you win by maneuver you don't win by
sitting still
and when you start talking about klaus
switz and mass
it's like we're here yes so
that's again i'm not trying to dude i'm
not trying to like
get crazy and to talk smack about klaus
fitz like i said
if you were a lance corporal at age 12
i salute you and i will listen to what
the hell you have to say a hundred
percent
but i will not
i will question anybody i questioned it
i questioned
hackworth you know re read my opening
like there's like hey man
guy was not guy was not perfect i mean
he's he you use him as the prime example
of a lesson we teach
in business all the time is if you lose
your influence
and he and and probably the most
influential figure in your life as a
leader is still your prime example of
what not to do
in a particular situation so i think the
contrarian component of it is is
important
look close woods is awesome on war is
awesome there's a bunch of good stuff in
there too
for sure and i know that you're saying
that but
just to link it back to that
conversation and and
the the human nature component
and thinking about the direct approach
and thinking of human nature if you just
thought before you took the direct
approach on anything
how would i react to somebody doing that
to me 99 of the indirect uh 99 of the
direct assaults would go away
if you could just take that perspective
on it
unless you lie to yourself
seriously yeah like unless you lie to
yourself which many many many people
will
do which is man i just want dave just to
comment hey
if i'm wrong just come and tell me yeah
like if you lie to yourself
then you you probably just keep taking
the direct approach all the time
yeah which is not gonna work out great
and if you're if you're the person
that prides themselves in listening to
other people's direct assault on you
there's high risk too that you are lying
to yourself
check all right back to the book one
defect of this definition that was the
definition of
of strategy which was
the art of employment of battles as
means to gain
the object of war so that that's klaus
fitz's
definition one defect of this definition
is that it
intrudes on the sphere of policy or the
higher conduct of war which must
necessarily be the responsibility of
government and not of military leaders
it employs as its agents in the
executive control of operations
so he's he's gonna go through this but
there's you know you know what we say
all the time
you can think strategic all the time
that's what he's about to
about to address 14 different ways and
he's going to actually go into
a chapter i don't know if we'll get
there today but there's a higher level
strategy called grand strategy
and so he's thinking grand strategy
policy
another defect is that it narrows the
meaning of strategy
to the pure utilization of battle
thus conveying the idea that battle is
the only means to the strategical
end it was an easy step for klaus whit's
less profound disciples to confuse the
means with the
end and to reach the conclusion that in
war in
every in war every other consideration
should be subordinated to the aim
of fighting a decisive battle
so so think about that that's your
attitude is like hey the whole purpose
of strategy is to
engage in decisive battle that's what
we're doing so then what do you do in
world war one
you put more people on the line and you
put more people on the line and you put
more people online you send another
battalion another
brigade another division over the top
that's what you do
and there's people that lead like this
in
companies and organizations in their
families and they
the way they lead is by trying to win
battles
that's the way they lead
and the commitment that every argument
is a decisive battle that has to be won
and not not being able to recognize
where and i think
i think he called them like inflection
points or something along the lines of
the recognition of
this is where it this is this is
decisive
and be able to recognize what an
inflection point is in combat
as opposed to like every in every
engagement is not an inflection point
it's not a decisive point and being able
to recognize where those points are
and and fighting those as opposed to
every single engagement you mean the
idea of picking your battles
hey pick your battles oh who's been told
that before yeah
hey pick your battles commons seems like
such common sense
and yet all the time people look at
every discussion
argument contention as the decisive
battle
for their ego yeah
relational policy to break down the
distinction between strategy and policy
would not matter much if the two
functions were normally combined in the
same person as with frederick or
napoleon
but but as such autocratic soldier
rulers have been rare in modern times
and became temporarily extinct for the
19th century the effect was insidiously
harmful
for it encouraged soldiers to make
preposterous claim that
policy should be subservient to their
conduct of operations
and especially in democratic countries
it drew statesmen on to
overstep the definite border of his
sphere and interfere with his military
employees in the actual use of their
tools
so there's got to be a line between
these two things and we got to stay in
our lanes a little bit
hey here's the policy how do you want to
execute it hey here's the resources i
need oh
don't know change your policy
reached a clearer and wiser definition
in terming strategy
quote the practical adaptation of the
means placed at a general's disposal
to the attainment of the object in view
monkey's another uh prussian guy
chief general in the 1860s
and uh he's the guy that kind of
i would say he had that the idea of the
oh making sure you have an overall
objective and make sure that people
understand what the overall objective is
the german word alph trogstactic
no overall objective
this definition it fixes the
responsibility of a military commander
to the government by which he is
employed
his responsibility is that of applying
most profitably
to the interest of higher war policy the
force allotted to him within the theater
of operations assigned to him
if he considers that to force a lot it
is inadequate for the task indicated
he is justified in putting this out and
if his opinion is
overruled he can refuse or resign
the command but he exceeds
his rightful sphere if he attempts to
dictate to the government what measure
force should be placed at his disposal
so like i said there's a line here that
he's talking about
on the other hand the government which
formulates war policy and has to adapt
to
it to conditions which often change as a
war progresses can rightly intervene in
the strategy of a campaign not merely by
replacing a commander
in whom it has lost confidence but by
modifying his object according to the
needs
of its war policy while it should not
interfere with him in handling
of his tools it should indicate clearly
nate the nature of his task
thus strategy has not necessarily the
simple object of seeking to overthrow
the enemy's military power
when a government appreciates that the
enemy has the military superiority
either in general or in a particular
theater it may be wise
to enjoin a strategy of limited
aim before i get into limited aim let's
tie this back to
corporate leadership and business
leadership what are you doing if you're
in charge
to make sure that you are empowering
your subordinate leaders
to make things happen and not saying hey
here's exactly how i want you to do it
here's what i want you to do with your
team here's what i want you to do with
your tools here's
that's when you're crossing the line you
shouldn't have to do that you shouldn't
have to have those conversations
we should be able to say hey dave this
is what we're trying to make happen
how do you want to do it yeah and dave
who's on the front lines says
hey boss here's what i'm thinking looks
good go execute
and by the way dave might come back soon
and say hey boss we can't do that unless
you give me some more resources
and i say hey that's all we got sorry
and you said well we need to cut back
then or we need to not do
this market area because we don't have
the we don't have the resources we need
okay cool
or maybe i say well i think it's just
because you suck
you're fired echo you got the con yeah
so let's make sure that we delineate the
roles and responsibilities clearly
enough that we know what
what we're trying to do up and down the
chain of command now
now to get back to this point of a
strategy of limited aim
he goes into it a little bit here this
is the strategy of limited limited aim
it may desire to wait until the balance
of force can be changed by the
intervention
intervention of allies or by the
transfer of forces from another theater
it may desire to wait or even limit its
military effort
permanently while economic or naval
action decides the issues
it may calculate that the overthrow of
the enemy's military power is a task
definitely beyond its capacity and not
worth the effort
and that the object of its war policy
can be assured by seizing territory
which it can
either retrain retain or use as a
bargaining counter
when peace is negotiated so so right
every one of those things is indirect
it's it's it's a it's a limited aim it's
like oh you know what i wanted to kick
dave's ass but he's way bigger and way
better at jiu jitsu than i thought he
was so you know what i'm gonna do
i'm gonna like say hey man instead of
let us fighting
why don't i buy you a hamburger
and we'll talk about some stuff and you
know what i'm saying like it's a
different it's just taking a different
approach it's a totally different
approach
you know what i i think dave can
actually kick my ass
echo's going to be here in about 30
minutes echo's
bigger and stronger than dave he's been
training more just so i'm gonna wait
till hey
hey hey dave do you mind if we i'd
rather have you roll with echo
right so i'm bringing in some
reinforcements
that's the strategy of limiting limited
aim such a policy has
more support from history than military
opinion
has recognized and is less inherently a
policy of weakness than some apologists
implies so
just because i say you know what dave
i'm not really looking to roll with you
i'm gonna wait till echo gets here
that's not necessarily weak in fact
it might be smarter in fact if i think
you can beat me and i'm pretty sure
you're going to beat me
it's way smarter for me to wait till
echo shows up to kick your ass
it is indeed bound up with the history
of the british empire and repeatedly
proved a
life buoy to britain's allies as well as
of the permanent benefit to herself
however unconsciously followed there's
ground for inquiry whether this
conservative military policy does not
deserve to be accorded
a place in the theory of the conduct of
war so how often did britain go yeah you
know what
maybe we don't want to fight that war
maybe we want to give that up maybe we
want to give that area up maybe we need
to
bargain and move move into an area that
we know we can take
and then we'll we'll negotiate for it
back later
the more usual reason for adopting a
strategy of limited aim
is that of awaiting a change in the
balance of force
wait until echo shows up a change often
sought and achieved by draining the
enemy's
force weakening him by pricks instead of
risking blows
what if while you know what hey dave i
don't you know i don't really want to
roll today
echo's going to be here in a little
while but while you're waiting why don't
you roll
a couple rounds with carrie and he wants
to roll a couple rounds with dean
and then so here you are fighting all
these battles by the time echo charles
shows up
fresh he's just had a discipline go he's
ready to rock and roll you're tired
you're nine rounds deep
that's my that's my that's a great plan
great plan
so i i weakened you by pricks
instead of risking blows the essential
condition of strategy such a strategy
is that the drain on him should be
disproportionately greater than on
oneself because i was sitting over
on the corner keeping time that's what i
was doing while you were rolling with
guy after guy after guy i'm
keeping track of time for you
the object may be sought by raiding his
supplies by local attacks which
annihilate or inflict disproportionate
loss on parts of his force by luring him
into unprofitable attacks
by causing an excessively wide
distribution on of his force
and no least by exhausting his moral and
physical energy this is like the exact
example
right i don't think i can kick your ass
but you know what echo's going to be
here in a little while and in the
meantime i'm going to entice
i'm going to go hey hey dean go get a
couple rounds go
go get a couple rounds with dave boom
and just rough you
up and gonna hit you with a couple
different people by the time echo shows
up
no factor that's what i'm doing yeah
and i'm also thinking of just the idea
of
even going to war with the american
military and and most of our opponents
certainly more recent history the aim
wasn't to destroy the american military
it was to make those
series of little pricks over time become
intolerable
where we are no longer willing to have
these little successive losses
so we're we're not going to have that
decisive campaign at all
because you made this intolerable for me
and that connection to policy too
we talk about that all the time of you
know the will you know somebody's will
to be doing that is hey
i don't want to keep doing this over and
over again these small little things
these little
those things add up over time as opposed
to like somehow
the objective is we're going to have a
force on force you know
culminating event between some military
in the american military which
which again generically speaking nobody
wants that
nobody wants to have a decisive
engagement with the american military so
we're going to do some other things
instead
and make that intolerable for us which
by the way
we suck in many areas of this the
united states in general think of the
propaganda damage that gets done to us
on a regular basis that has been done to
us on a regular basis
basically since vietnam anytime we get
into
i mean anytime we get into a conflict
now the propaganda that is
used to turn us against ourselves and
this country is it's
it's crazy how effective it is
if you look at the vietnam war
it's crazy how effective they were yeah
at turning
americans against americans in that
war yeah
back to the book this closer definition
sheds light on the question
previously raised of a general's
independence in carrying out his own
strategy inside his theater of
operations
for if the for if the government has
decided upon a limited aim
or grand strategy the general who even
within his strategic fear seeks to
overthrow the enemy's military power
may do more harm than good to the
government's war policy
so what is that saying that's saying
like i got dave out there he's super
aggressive and he's like you know what
i'm gonna
i'm gonna take this whole area and
meanwhile i'm thinking dave don't take
that whole area then we're gonna have to
occupy it i don't have the people to
occupied and now we're going to cause
more problems
so just because you're winning doesn't
mean you're winning
usually a war of limited aim a war
policy of limited aim
imposes a strategy of limited aim and a
decisive aim should only be adopted with
the approval of the government
which alone can decide whether it is
worth the candle old school expression
i didn't really know what it meant i had
to look it up worth the candle means
we're gonna do something is what we're
doing worth
the candle that the light it's going to
take to for us to be able to do whatever
we're doing yeah
is it worth the candle like we're going
to oh we got some work to do tonight
cool light the candle but how much are
we really going to get done it's not
worth the candle
this is back in the day kind of like is
the juice worth it
it's worth the squeeze exactly
we can now arrive at a shorter
definition of strategy
as quote the art of distributing and
applying military means to
fulfill the ends of policy end quote
for strategy is concerned not merely
with the movement of forces
as its role is often defined but with
the effect
when the application of the military
instrument merges into actual fighting
the dispositions for and control
of such direct action are termed tactics
the two categories although convenient
for discussion can never be truly
divided into separate compartments
because each each not only influences
but merges
into the other which is why leadership
strategy and taxes is called leadership
strategy and tactics
kind of convenient that it worked out
that way
but but listen here's what's important
is what we're doing it doesn't matter
what matters is how it ends up yeah what
matters is the strategic effect that's
why we have to think strategic all the
time
that's what we need to do
next section higher or grand strategy as
tactics in as tactics is an application
of strategy on a lower plane
so strategy is an application on a lower
plane of grand strategy so he goes one
level up
a whole nother thing we got tactical we
got operational
he doesn't really talk about operational
that must be a modern thing tactical
operational strategic and then grand
strategy while practically synonymous
with policy
what was your would you study in college
policy
dang what's up man do you want to chime
in bit i do let us know
you're rolling man but i mean there
there's so much kloss whizzy and stuff
in there but
the the previous comment it was as i'm
thinking of sort of like
the business alignment of this this
military
uh concept is how often are we are we
engaged in tactical battles
that don't promote or support the
strategic goal
and i think it was i think it was the
debrief podcast but you said this is
if what you were doing if
the tactical engagement you're in
supports
the the big picture strategy it's not
tactical it's strategic
and if it doesn't it's tactical and
you're engaged
you shouldn't be doing it like how often
do we dig in
on these these small things that even in
the end if we win
don't reinforce the big picture goal the
objective
and how often do i on with my team the
marketing team
dig in on how i want to do this this
thing and i'm going to fight with the
the sales team over resources and
supplies and equipment and priority
that don't actually help the company the
company
achieves some some sort of success and
being able to look at that as a leader
and going
hey hey listen this this doesn't matter
this
we don't need to dig in here let them
have this we're playing the longer game
here because what we want is the company
to win
and how hard it is for us to decouple
this idea that every battle is a
strategic
no it's not it's not very few of my very
few yeah
absolutely
um for the role of grand strategy
higher strategy is to coordinate and
direct all the resources of a nation or
band of nations towards the attainment
of a political object
of the war the goal defined by
fundamental policy
grand strategy should both calculate and
develop to economic resources and
manpower of nations in order to
sustain fighting services also the moral
resources for the foster the people's
willing spirit
is often as important as to possess
more concrete forms of power which is
why you need to pay attention
to what's going on in your country when
it comes to propaganda that's being
used against you grand strategy too
should regulate the distribution of
power between the
several services and between the
services
and industry moreover
fighting power is but one of the
instruments of grand strategy
which should take account of and
apply the power of financial pressure
diplomatic pressure
commercial pressure and least of
ethical pressure to weaken the
opponent's will
a good cause is a sword as well
as armor likewise
chivalry in war can be a most effective
weapon in
weakening the opponent's will to resist
as well as
augmenting moral strength this is why
we always say take the high ground to
the hydra thank you yeah
take the high ground take the high
ground to the good cause is a sword as
well as armor
and and when you give up the high ground
when you get down into the mud and i
think there's a quote you've references
when you get down in the mud you're not
getting muddy because somebody's
throwing mud at you it's because you
went
down there and how hard it is once
you've got up the high ground
to get back up onto the high ground once
you give that up
back to the book furthermore while the
horizon of strategy is bounded by
by the war grand strategy looks beyond
the war
to the subsequent peace it should not
only combine
the various instruments but so regulate
their use as to avoid
damage to the future state of peace for
its security and prosperity
the sorry state of peace for both sides
that has followed most wars can be
traced to the fact that unlike strategy
the realm of grand strategy is for the
most part
terra incognita
still awaiting exploration and
understanding that means unknown
territory
so this is this is you know beyond
thinking strategic and it's kind of the
way we
term thinking strategic you know if if
you and i have a relationship and
i'm gonna bark and order you where does
that get me even if you do that thing
where does it put us in the future
how's our relationship if we
have a client and we decide you know
what we're going to bill them anyways
even though they didn't you know they
didn't participate but we're going to
bill them anyways
how's that going to work out for us cool
we get a little bit more money right now
how does that how does that affect us in
a year when that client needs help
so the grand strategy looks beyond the
ward a subsequent piece
how often are we doing that looking
further in the future
goes into pure or military strategy
having cleared the ground we can build
up our conception of strategy on its
proper plane
and original basis that of the art of
the general strategy depends for success
first and foremost
first and foremost first sorry first and
most on a sound
calculation and coordination of the ends
and means of the end and means
the end must be proportioned to the
total means
and the means used in gaining each
intermediate end
which contributes to the ultimate must
be proportioned to the value and the
needs of that
intermediate end whether it be to gain
an objective or fulfill
a contributory purpose
and excess may be as harmful as a
deficiency so that's
first of all that's a freaking run-on
sentence but
but second of all but second of all it's
important
because what he's saying is you should
constantly be assessing if
if the juice is worth the squeeze you
should constantly be saying like listen
we're going to put this much effort
towards this client or we're going to
put this much effort towards this
relationship we're going to put this
much effort towards this team
who's we don't know how they're going to
do so you constantly have to
check yourself if the end that you're
going towards
is your investment worth it what's the
roi
and by the way spending too much it can
be as bad as not spending enough totally
and and and spending a much to to win a
particular battle or
win a particular war but you spent so
much so you look around and go
well that was not the juice wasn't worth
the squeeze it wasn't worth the candle
yeah what do we accomplish
and that that next level up to grand
strategy
and of course i think the connection
he's making is on this large scale man i
literally took a class called american
grand strategy
check and the military is a is a
is a component of all these other things
you named a bunch of them diplomatic
you know uh economic there's a whole
bunch of different tools that are inside
there that are actually
you know they're all connected but the
military is one arm of that
one of many of course you're in uniform
you think the whole world revolves
around military power we know we say it
all the time we know that's not true
but an example that you use all the time
in in just trying to explain
this idea of utilizing resources and
making decisions
when you talk about means our means
everybody has limited means we don't
have
unlimited means or unlimited resources
and
if i'm looking at this particular area i
want to i want to open up a shop here
open up a couple of locations in this
physical uh you know this geographic
area to compete with our
competitors and i take all of my
resources
every penny i've got every tool that
i've got and i get in there go bake or
go home that's right
and in the end we get in there we get in
that region
and i don't know it doesn't quite work
out or even if it does but we now have
no
other tools and resources to do anything
else
the larger piece of that is the strategy
isn't
to get into that area the strategy is
actually to make our company
stronger and that limited understanding
or that understanding
being limited of hey we're here to take
over this region
if that is not connected to the company
being successful that larger piece of it
all the all the means or all the
resources to getting into that area
they don't help you waste it it's a
waste you burn that candle yeah
yeah uh and you know what's interesting
is from a leadership
this is a totally this is a leadership
capital discussion right
it's hey is it worth me expending this
leadership capital
on getting dave to follow my order
on getting dave to you know pick up a
client that i know is going to be
painful
and i'm forcing him to do it and
whatever whatever the case may be
is it worth that leadership capital we
we have to weigh that out and you know
when you were talking about oh we got
the
the diplomatic we got the the
the commercial pressure the financial
pressure the ethical pressure all those
things
and the military's part of that guess
what in from a leadership perspective
the military thing is hey this is my
rank i outrank you and we're just going
to go by force
that's force that should be there's six
seven eight twelve other components that
i can utilize as a leader to make
something happen
and the worst one to use the one that
cost me the most leadership capital is
the military one which is my rank which
is
hey i'm the boss you sh you listen to me
to compel someone through the threat of
force as your only tool to get them to
comply
the threat of force and even you know
the the the moral high ground i mean how
convenient would it be if you and i were
in a situation looking at something and
mine was the moral approach and yours
was the immoral approach
which requires no money no time no
resources no equipment you go oh you
know what
hey listen if we do this we take the if
we take the unethical and we get found
out
and somebody just goes oh hey man you're
right you no
listen man i was you're right we we need
to do just we just need to do the right
thing here
the the strategic win from that alone
or the opposite end of the spectrum the
military end is
i come through force and demand and
through risk of
of destruction is how i'm getting you to
behave in a way that helps the team yeah
i've got this quote later on and i don't
even remember where i got the quote from
but i talked about on this podcast
maybe i talked about an ef online it's
it's something along the lines of
cool you win and now you're in charge of
a wasteland great
oh yeah you won the war cool now you
have uh burnt scorched earth that's what
you have
cool good job what did you win nothing
yeah
back to the book a true oh this is a
true adjustment
would establish a perfect economy of
force
in the deeper sense of that oft
distorted military term so all the time
we heard the term
economy of force but because of the
nature and uncertainty of war
and uncertainty increased by lack of
scientific study even the greatest
military ability could not achieve a
true adjustment and success lies in the
closest
approximation to the truth again his use
of the word truth is a little bit
is a little bit broad but what he's
talking about how much should i apply to
this
how much force should i apply we want to
apply the minimum force required
but we're not going to be perfect with
that so we want to get as close as we
can
this relativity is inherent because
however our knowledge and
of the science of war be extended it
will depend on the art
for its application art can not only
bring the end nearer to the means
but by giving a higher value to the
means enable
the end to be extended
this complicates calculation because no
man can exactly calculate the capacity
of human
genius and stupidity
nor the incapacity of will so there's
all these things that we have to
account for as leaders you know and
we're and
and we're not going to get it perfectly
right but how close can we get it
next section elements and conditions in
strategy however
calculation is simpler and a closer
approximation to
truth possible than in tactics so this
is a very interesting
it's easier to calculate big broad
strategic things because you're a little
bit
further away from the the human
component
for in war the chief incalculable is the
human will which manifests itself in
resistance which in turn
lies in the province of tactics strategy
has not to overcome resistance except
from nature its purpose is to diminish
the possibility of resistance
and it seeks to fulfill this purpose by
exploiting the elements of
movement and surprise now that's cool
and everything
i would say that there's definitely
that's a stretch
because we've seen collect the
collective will
of a people change
the outcome of strategic situations for
sure
so even though i said hey it's
it's closer to it still can have a huge
impact i mean look at vietnam it was
like oh
well we can beat them because we can
kill 150 vietnamese soldiers
and viet cong soldiers for every one of
our people that killed so we'll win no
actually we won't win
right because guess what their
collective
will is freaking incredibly strong
yeah but movement and surprise
movement lies in the physical sphere and
depends on calculation of the conditions
of the time topography
and transport capacity by transport
capacity has meant both the
both the means by which and the measure
in which force can be moved and
maintained okay
so there's the physical fear sphere of
movement
surprise lies in the psychological
sphere and depends on a calculation
far more difficult than in the physical
sphere of the manifold conditions
varying in each case
which are likely to affect the will of
the opponent
so you got two things you've got
movement and you've got surprise this is
how we're gonna kind of win
this is how we're gonna win by movement
and surprise movement physical
surprise psychological although strategy
may
aim more at exploiting movement than at
exploiting surprise or conversely the
two elements
react on each other so even though
they're different
spheres they're still closely woven
together
movement generates surprise and surprise
gives
impetus to movement so this is jujitsu
right if you surprise somebody
they have to react to it so you can make
someone move by surprising them with
something
for a movement which is accelerated or
changes its direction
inevitably carries with it a degree of
surprise
even though it be concealed while
surprise smooths the path of movement
by hindering the enemies counter
measures
and counter movements so if i surprise
you you don't have time to react to it
you're not defending it yeah
this is obviously not something this guy
was thinking about when i think about
flying in stealth airplanes the
psychology of that is
what i what i have discovered and it's
true not just an airplane it's true in
every situation
more often than not people's reaction to
being surprised is not the right
reaction they don't usually react well
even when they react it's still like an
overreaction under reaction
think about how you react to when you're
surprised are those usually like
good smooth effective responses 100
yeah all the time and
when when you look at stealth airplanes
the advent of americans showing up with
stealth airplanes and sort of the
culminating event really was in desert
storm
when nobody even knew we had them and
all of a sudden stealth airplanes are
over baghdad dropping bombs
and the iraqis didn't under they did not
understand what was happening
and their reaction was obviously wrong
now you know
that they're proliferated that's why a
significantly undersized force when
you're flying around in a stealth
aircraft
and then i'm fighting against you and
your conventional aircraft and the first
call you hear is
hey the first four of your airplanes are
all dead
and and the psychological response to
that
is almost always the wrong response the
reaction they they behave erratically
they move in different direct
they don't know what to do the
psychological response to surprise is
almost always the wrong reaction
and the power of creating
that reaction in your opponents is
really hard to overstate and that's
really
one of the things that stealth airplanes
have allowed us to do is get our
opponents
to behave incorrectly to give us an even
more of an advantage
you're going to off-balance them somehow
because what you just said when you say
they either overreact or under react
guess what
you either you're off balance right a
balanced measured response would be like
okay we didn't really get them off
balance but you
either overreact or you underreact and
through surprise
you cause them to move too far in one
direction too far in the other direction
that's what's gonna happen and that's
what we're gonna take advantage of
and you've explained this a ton like if
i attack your arm
and you under react to a point where you
do not almost don't react at all and you
just let me have it then
i may actually culminate with an armbar
yeah
but more than likely you're gonna
overreact and i want you to overreact to
that so i can attack something else
but it's like you said it's it's the
lack of a balanced response it's usually
an overreaction
usually that reveals a weakness
somewhere else that i can then exploit
yep as regards
the relation of strategy and tactics
while in
execution the borderline is often
shadowy
and it is difficult to decide exactly
where a strategical movement ends and a
tactical movement begins yet in
conception
the two are distinct tactics lies
in the fills tactics lies and fills the
province of fighting
strategy not only stops on the frontier
but has for its purpose
the reduction of fighting by the
slenderest
possible proportions so the purpose of
strategy is to not
fight
goes on with the aim of strategy this
statement may be disputed by those who
conceive
the destruction of the enemy's armed
force as the only sound aim in war
who hold that the only goal of strategy
is battle
and who are obsessed with the klaus
fission saying
that blood is the price of victory
yet if one should concede this point and
meet its advocates on their own ground
the statement would remain
unshaken for even if decisive battle be
the goal
the aim of strategy must be to bring
about this battle
under the most advantageous
circumstances
and the more advantageous the
circumstances the less proportionately
will be the fighting
it's a whole goal of strategies we're
not fighting that's what we're doing
the perfection of strategy would be
therefore to produce a decision without
any serious fighting
history now think about that from a
leadership perspective
i never get in an argument because
dave's doing what i need him to do to
make it happen
that's the most effective strategy it's
not how do i outwit dave in an
argument that doesn't matter why am i
having an argument
history as we have seen provides
examples where strategy helped by
favorable conditions
has virtually produced such a result and
he goes through some examples here
and again he's he's recalling back to
some of the examples that he talks about
in the book
while these cases while these were cases
where the destruction of the enemy's
forces
the enemy's armed forces was
economically achieved through the
disarming
by surrender such destruction may
not be essential for a decision and for
the fulfillment
of the war aim in the case of a state
that is seeking not
conquest but maintenance of a secure of
its security
the aim is fulfilled if the threat be
removed if the enemy is led to abandon
his purpose
with such while such bloodless victories
have been exceptional
their rarity enhances rather than
detracts from their value
as an indication of latent
potentialities
in strategy and grand strategy despite
many centuries
of experience of war we have hardly
begun to explore the field of
psychological warfare from deep study of
war klaus fitz
was led to the conclusion that quote all
military action is permeated by
intelligent forces
and their effects nevertheless
end quote nevertheless nations at war
have always striven or been driven by
their passions
to disregard the implications of such a
conclusion instead of applying
intelligence
they have chosen to batter their heads
against the nearest wall
so here's klaus so it's like hey it's
it's an intelligence yeah
you know we're doing what but all the
time we
countries people leaders teams we get we
do
stupid things we bang our heads against
the nearest wall because we get
emotional we're not intelligent
and we gotta look out for that
it rests normally with the government
responsible for the grand strategy of
award to decide whether strategy should
make its contribution by achieving a
military decision
or otherwise just as military means is
only one of the means to the end of
grand strategy one of the instruments
in the surgeon's case so battle is only
one of the means to the end
of strategy if the conditions are
suitable
usually it is usually the quickest in
effect
but if conditions are unfavorable it's a
folly to use so cool you can go to
battle
but if you haven't prepared for it and
you don't have the advantage it's stupid
let's assume that a strategist is
empowered to seek a military decision
his responsibility is to seek it under
the most advantageous circumstances in
order to produce the most profitable
result
hence his true aim is not so much to
seek
battle as to seek a strategic situation
so advantageous that if it does not
of itself produce the decision its
continuation by battle
is sure to achieve this
so we're not engaging in battles that we
don't know we're gonna win
and if we know we're going to win them
why can't we convince the opponent that
we're going to win and they
bow down yeah in other words dislocation
is the aim of strategy
its sequel may be either the enemy's
dissolution
or his easier disruption in battle
dissolution may involve some partial
measure of fighting but this is not
but this is not the character of battle
so
that's what we're trying to do we're
trying to win the fight without fighting
we're trying to win the argument without
having it i'm trying to get dave one out
to do what i want him to do without
him even knowing that that's what i want
him to do it's his idea yeah
and think about that statement about you
getting me to do
do it do what you want me to get done
without fighting with me
and take a step away from this book
which is talking about
fighting your enemies like your literal
enemies
to someone on your team on my team my
team
my guy yeah because the human nature
doesn't change
it doesn't change if we're in the jungle
desert if we're in 1842
if we're in 1916 if we're in 1942 it
doesn't matter
if you're my enemy or you're my friend
if there's if there's a component of
human will then we need to utilize these
principles effectively
next section action of strategy how is
the strategic dislocation produced
in the physical or logistical sphere it
is the result of a move which
a upsets the enemy's dispositions and by
compelling a sudden change of front
dislocates the distribution
and organization of his forces b
separates his forces
god i got a little a little little
little
tingle in my spine when i saw that
endangers
his supplies d menaces the root or roots
by which
he could retreat in case of need
and re-establish himself on the base so
there's these ways that we can
cause strategic dislocation
a dislocation may be produced by one of
these effects but is more often a
consequence of several
right we're gonna we're gonna dislocate
them from multiple different directions
differentiation indeed is difficult
because a move directed toward the
enemy's rear tends to combine these
effects
their respective influence however
varies and has varied throughout history
according the size of armies and
complexities of their organization
with armies which live on the country
drawing their supplies locally
by plunder requisition the line of
communication
has negligible importance so if you've
got an army that's out there living off
the land they kind of know what they're
doing
you can you don't you can't really cut
their supply lines because they don't
have any
even if a higher even in a higher stage
of military development
the smaller a force the less dependent
it is on the lines of communication for
supplies
the larger an army and more complex its
organization the more prompt and serious
in effect is a menace to its line of
communication
so depending on who you're fighting
you've got to make some adjustments
where armies have not been so dependent
strategy has been correspondingly
handicapped that and the tactical issue
of battle has played a greater part
nevertheless even thus handicapped
able strategists have frequently gained
a decisive advantage
previous to battle by menacing the
enemy's lines of retreat
the equilibrium of his dispositions or
his local supplies
that's what we're doing so we're
throwing people off just by messing with
the supply chain by messing with their
communication
and by the way i'm probably going to
mention this 15
15 000 more times he's talking all the
time about
disrupting your enemy's communication
each one of those is the red cell
the red team for us to go man am i
communicating properly every time you
hear
that's one of the main ways that the
indirect
approach works is by disrupting the
enemy communication
what does that tell us about our
communication it tells us it's freaking
critical
he goes into some some uh
talk about how to disrupt
communication to be effective such a
menace usually must be applied at a
point closer in time and space to the
enemy's army
than a menace to his communication and
thus early in warfare it's often
difficult to distinguish between
strategical and tactical maneuver
in the psychological sphere dislocation
is the result of the impression
on the commander's mind of the physical
effects
which we have listed the impression is
strongly accentuated if his realization
of being at a disadvantage is sudden
and if he feels that he is unable to
counter an enemy's move
psychological dislocation fundamentally
springs
from his sense of being trapped
that's straight out of like the jujitsu
world yes sir
and this is important so we feel we feel
dislocated we feel nervous when we get
trapped
guess what you should never do as a
leader
hey dave i know you want to do this but
what if that happens why am i trapping
him
why am i trapping you don't trap people
that are on your team
that's another little red cell little
red team
if you're tr if i set you up to trap you
you're going to be uncomfortable you're
going to get defensive you're going to
be unstable
and my interest in interacting with you
the next time
you know like oh here we go let's see
what what jocko is going to try to do to
me this time
talking about loyalty and respect and
the things that you actually want from
me in the end
you know when when when you're the
leader that likes to set your people up
so you can hammer them
dude that's a classic like i won that
argument on that argument
man that worked out for you in that
meeting
good job he won't want to step up again
this is the reason why it is most
frequently followed
a physical move on the enemy's rear an
army like a man cannot properly defend
its back from a blow without turning
around to use its arms in a new
direction
turning temporarily unbalances an army
as it does a man
and with the former the period of
instability is inevitably much longer
in consequence the brain is much more
sensitive to any menace to its back
oh this is why in jiu jitsu what are we
trying to do we're trying to attack the
back that's why in the
battlefield we're trying to we're trying
to come around to the rear
because then they have to maneuver and
face you and they're exposed
in in contrast to move directly on an
opponent
consolidates his balance physical and
psychologically
and by consolidating it increases his
resisting power
when i attack you from the front you
know exactly what's coming at you and
you can resist it more
what does that mean from a leadership
perspective
that means that i i don't want to
have you resist my ideas by coming right
at you
for in the case of an army it rolls the
enemy back towards the reserve supplies
and reinforcements so the original front
is driven back and warned thin
new layers are added to the back so when
you make the enemy retreat well guess
what this is what the russians did to
napoleon and to the nazis
we're just going to retreat yeah yeah
you good job you beat us today
cool we just got closer to our supply
chain yeah we just got more
reinforcements our communication lines
got
got shorter you made our job easier
at the most it imposes a strain rather
than producing a shock thus a move
around to the enemy's rear against
the a move around the enemy's front
against his rear has the aim not only of
avoiding resistance on its way
but in its issue in the profoundest
sense
it takes the line of least resistance
the equivalent in this psychological
sphere is the line of least
expectation they are two faces of the
same coin
this is to widen our understanding of
strategy if we merely take what
obviously appears the line of least
resistance
its obviousness will appeal to the
opponent also and this line may no
longer be
the line of least resistance
used to when we used to go on recons
reconnaissance missions
and we'd get put on reconnaissance
missions like camp pendleton and you get
up to camp pendleton
and you're supposed to be observing some
area and there's a one spot to
observe from there's like one bush
you're like
we cannot it's so tempting to go to that
bush but guess
exactly where the they're gonna look
they're gonna look at that bush so
you're better off
digging a hole doing whatever you got to
do taking the worst
looking bush you know there's four
bushes three of them are
pretty good one of them sucks go to the
one that sucks
in studying the physical aspect we must
never lose sight of the psychological
and when both are combined is the
strategy truly an indirect approach
calculated dislocate the opponent's
balance
the mere action of marching indirectly
toward the enemy and on the rear of his
dispositions has not constituted
the strategic and direct approach so
just because you try and come around the
rear doesn't mean
because if that's what they think you're
going to do it doesn't matter
strategic art is not so simple such an
approach may start by being an indirect
relation to an enemy's front but by the
very directness of its progress towards
the rear
may allow the enemy to change his
disposition so that soon becomes a
direct approach
a direct approach on a new front check
because of the risk that the enemy may
achieve such a change of front it is
usually necessary for the dislocating
move to be preceded by a move or
moves which can best be defined as the
term
distract in a literal sense to draw
asunder
so we have to do multiple moves just
like in jiu jitsu you can't just do one
move
you can't resin you can't really even
just do two you got to do multiple moves
to make the enemy not sure what's really
important
what's really going on and you know i
was i was doing a little bit of research
because i always
people will sometimes bring up d-day
what about d-day
frontal assault right yep yeah kind of
guess what the deception that the allied
forces did
to make hitler and the nazis
unaware i think it was something like
i don't think hitler committed all of
his forces to normandy for
seven weeks because they were expecting
general patton
that was the whole big scam like hey we
got pat and he's gonna come in this
other
spot and and so for seven weeks the
nazis were like no don't commit
so even though it was it looked like a
direct assault there was a massive fake
going on
that that germany didn't commit their
forces for seven
weeks that's crazy
so it looked like a frontal soul i get
it but man there was some distraction
going on
well just like he was he was just saying
it's it's it's only a frontal assault if
the enemy recognizes
as a frontal assault and then lines up
his defenses against that frontal
assault
and the psychology of that the human
nature reaction is the thing that
actually matters the most
is your response to my interaction and
if you think it's a frontal assault
they're going to react like it's a
frontal assault and you're going to dig
in
and it was like hey something's going
something's going on here like actually
it's a frontal assault you don't know it
yeah it actually isn't a funnel at all
it's a flank because they are putting
their defenses elsewhere
yeah the purpose of this distraction is
to deprive the enemy of his freedom of
action and it should operate both the
physical and psychological fear
spheres in the physical it should cause
a distension of his forces
or their diversion to unprofitable ends
so that they are too
widely distributed and too committed
elsewhere this is exactly what d-day was
to have the power of interfering with
one's own decisively intended move which
was
we're gonna hit it in the psychological
fear sphere
the same effect is sought by playing
upon the fears this the fears of and by
deceiving
the opposing command stonewall jackson
aptly
expressed this in his strategical motto
mystify mislead and surprise
fur to mystify and mislead constitutes
distraction while surprise is the
essential cause of dislocation
is through the distraction of the
commander's mind that the distraction of
his forces
follows the loss of his freedom of
action is the sequel to the loss of his
freedom of conception
a more profound appreciation of how the
psychological permeates and dominates
the physical
sphere has an indirect value for it
warns us of the fallacy
and shallowness of attempting to analyze
and theorize
about strategy in terms of mathematics
to treat it quantitatively as if the
issue turned merely on superior
concentration of force
at a selected place is as faulty as to
treat it geometrically
as a matter of lines and angles
it's not just numbers
even more remote from the truth because
in practice it usually leads to
a dead end is the tendency of textbooks
to treat war
as mainly a matter of concentrating
superior force
in his celebrated definition of economy
of force
fock termed this the art
of pouring out all one's resources at a
given moment on one spot of making use
there of all truths and to make such a
thing possible
of making those troops permanently
communicate with each other instead of
dividing them and attaching
to each fraction some fixed and
invariable function
its second part a result having been
attained
is the art of again so disposing the
troops as to converge upon
and act against a single new objective
end quote
it would have been so so there's the
there's the uh economy of force like hey
we're going to put
all of our forces in the right spot at
the right time
which we all know we learn that all the
time and that's that's part of
prioritize and execute
that is part of prioritize and execute
is listen you got multiple things you
need to
concentrate your forces on
an objective efficiently
it would have been more exact and he's
going to take up a little
a little hit on this quote from from fox
who by the way this is
birdman uh uh ferdinand fox this is the
the french allied commander world war
one
so we kind of already aren't super
stoked on him
because guess what he did he carried out
his strategy
hey well we got to get more forces as we
got to do concentrate all our forces
when we blow that whistle we're going to
break through this
time no
here's why it would have been more exact
and more lucid to say that an army
should always be so
distrib distribute distributed that its
parts can aid each other and combine
to produce the maximum possible
concentration of
force at one place while the minimum
force necessary is used elsewhere to
prepare the success
of the concentration this is what cover
and move is
this is what cover and move is is you
and and there's a doctrinal term and i
used to tell this to the young seals
there's a doctrinal term
called supporting distance and what
supporting distance is
you dave and me your platoon and my
platoon or your
company and my company or your battalion
and my battalion we aren't going to get
so far apart that we can't support each
other so that means if
if we only have rifles we're going to be
400 500 yards from each other you know
depending on the terrain if the terrain
is
you know mountainous or we might be
closer than that because
i want to be able to provide support to
you if we have mortars cool now we can
stretch it out a little bit more
if we have artillery we can stretch it
out even more but
we need to be able to cover and move for
each other
we need to be able to support each other
and if we get too far apart
you're alone man we had a term that we
got to coin it was called fluid mutual
support
which is wait when you said we got to
coin this expand bro
so this is freaking good deal dave over
here making stuff up
listen i'm listening when we at top guns
figured out like we used to have just
superior equipment
superior technology better machines more
of them they worked better
and we were fighting and i think i
talked about this a while ago we were
firing in
fighting an inferior opponent to be
totally honest with you
our tactics were kind of straightforward
it just wasn't that complicated now we
didn't just like barge right in there
and fight him but you know our tactics
relied on the fact that in the end our
stuff was better than your stuff and if
it's flown correctly well
over time we couldn't rely on that
anymore their equipment got better than
ours they were able to do things we
couldn't do
and what we had to start doing is taking
that same equipment and start to utilize
them differently
and one of the things we had to get away
from was cover and move for airplanes
used to be a thousand feet away
two thousand feet away and you stay
together i turn you turn you i go you go
and your job as a wingman and how i
graded your performance as a wingman is
how well you stayed
inside that what we called visual visual
mutual sport it was like
and if you lost sight of me believe me
we you were gonna hear about in the
debrief
yeah and what we
evolved to was because of inferior
equipment
we had to actually get farther away from
each other
so in simplest terms we could figure out
who was the person who was the aircraft
in the formation
that was fundamentally the most at risk
or the most likely to be engaged and the
other
aircraft could then flank or maneuver or
come in from a different
three-dimensional direction
to support that person and it was fluid
because
it changed it wasn't exactly on the 35
degree bearing line
at five miles it it evolved
based on weather based on weapons based
on the formation and just like you
described as and i had to know and if i
got too far away i couldn't support you
and if i was too close to you i couldn't
maneuver in a way that allowed me to
have
an advantageous entry to the problem a
flank
because i was too too close to you and
and while you were talking about that i
was just thinking of
the french approach to world war one
this culminating thing versus
just the standard combined arms effect
oh cool i don't need a million tanks
i got a couple tanks here you don't want
to rocket the tanks cool they're going
to run you over you want to react to the
tanks cool come out here holes we're
going to get you with artillery you
don't want to deal that artillery you're
going to dig in cool i'll roll in with
an aircraft
and i don't need an overwhelming force
of any of those three
but i i need them together in support of
one another
and i don't know in the end who's going
to get the kill or who's going to be the
reason why i'm successful
but you're going to have to react to
something and if you don't one of those
different arms those different
supporting elements
will eventually be the thing that causes
you to lose
supporting distance cover and move
and and now fluid mutual support
we better i'm gonna dude i should have
known that i was gonna
totally submarine your goals of getting
through this by talking way too much
i i i planned for this so
we'll we'll wrap it up with another
paragraph and then we'll we'll we'll do
the next on the next podcast
here's where he's gonna break down uh
fox's statement a little bit
he says because fox said uh the art of
pouring
all one's resources so
so liedell hart says the concentrate all
is an unrealizable ideal and dangerous
even as a hyperbole
moreover in practice the minimum
necessary
may be a far larger portion of the total
than maximum possible it would even be
true to say that the larger
the force that is effectively used for
distraction of the enemy the greater the
chance
of the concentration succeeding in its
aim
for otherwise it may strike an
object too solid to be shattered
this is like um in jiu jitsu
if you if i try and sweep you
but it's i'm not really trying to sweep
you you don't even have to react to it
i have to really try and sweep you then
if i really try and sweep you then you
expose your neck
boom cool you stick your neck out to you
you know you push into me and boom
there's your neck i can get the
guillotine
if i don't actually put enough force to
get but if i put
too much force into that it and you
defend it well well now i've used a
bunch of energy and it didn't work
and how often am i going to do that
so we have to be careful and what he's
saying is you want to use this from what
we talk a lot about
a lot about at echelon front which is
minimum force required
like how much force do i need to use to
get you to react
and if if i only have to use you know
ten percent of my force over here to get
you to react
that means i have ninety percent of my
force to finish your finish the job on
the flank
closing this out superior weight at the
intended decisive point does not
suffice unless that point cannot be
reinforced in time by the opponent
yeah you can you can put a bunch i can
go for your arm but if you're going to
grab with your other arm and defend it
well it doesn't matter that i
singled out your arm it rarely suffices
unless that point is not merely weaker
numerically but has been weakened
morally napoleon suffered some of his
worst
checks because he neglected this
guarantee and the need for distraction
has grown
with the delaying power of weapons
so there you go that's a warm up we're
almost two and a half hours deep right
now
we're talking it's it's only gonna get
deeper from here
um let's let's call it for right now
let's get into some
i don't know echo charles maybe the uh
anything any closing statements dave
all right let's let's roll into a little
little quick uh activity with
you know maybe a little bit of support
sure
uh you know i know we're trying to be
indirect but maybe there's some direct
ways we can kind of
help ourselves out sure what do you got
or some help in our
on our path which includes being
indirect as far as
effectiveness goes concur yeah so i was
talking with
our friend carrie and you and i just
kind of come to realize that this path
is not that hard anymore
it's hard but it's not as hard are you
talking about the path
the path okay that we're all on and is
why i didn't know that
this is when the path just got easier a
little bit easier okay more light
yeah easier it's not easy okay oh it's
hard still but it's easier
in this way chocolate fuel boom this is
why you drink energy drinks that's no
longer a problem
if you're on the path and you're like
into energy drink spray you got to get
rid of those
and sometimes it'll take willpower i
understand you know at the very least an
adjustment period that might not be very
comfortable
yeah but it's not like that anymore
drink all the energy drinks you want
anymore discipline go
energy drinks good for you boom path
easier yeah
right then adjustment yeah i have to
concur the pattern it just got easier
controls with the correct it's true also
we want to have dessert right yeah well
if you're on the path
well you gotta you gotta start excluding
dessert from time to time
in fact pretty much all the time on the
path yeah the
occasional dessert can happen i mean
yeah
my daughter's birthday yesterday yes sir
i understand um
i was at raglan which is kind of like
one of my
go-to might be my favorite restaurant
that's your jam yeah
and they have that that cast iron pan
with the
chocolate chip it's yeah they call it
the illegal yeah
it's good they're like it's so good it
should be illegal
good name so we had to order some
illegals
from my daughter's birthday that's her
birthday right
get that illegal girl right so when it
showed up
the ice cream just melts in the pan dude
it's a whole nother situation yeah i
understand
let's face it to your point we can't be
doing that you know every day
every day exactly we would love to
probably not even more than
once per month what if you could though
because you don't do it for the illegal
necessarily most of us
we do it because hey that that thing
tastes good yeah you know let's face it
after dinner raglan's i'm assuming you
got some steak or something like this
it's not like you're like starving and
hungry after the steak you just want
something sweet
yeah that's it's it's this is sad so you
get that
so you get it you get the illegal you
got your thing sweet cool
but you pay a price yep now on this new
path
we don't got to pay the price look at
that easier do it every day
we're talking about multiple i am
talking about i'm talking about the monk
train
all day man all day so anyway yeah so
and you get additional protein
in the form of this dessert so boom
right there
path a little bit easier you see what
i'm saying easier yeah
um good news is also we got some other
supporting elements
uh for your joints joint warfare super
cool oil we got stuff
for you immunity well you know what
you're saying right now is
actually a pretty big deal like if you
think about if you think about the
the fact that someone right now was like
well
they're drinking three energy drinks a
day
yeah and it's not good for them and it
is gonna have long-term
negative health effects legitimate well
they're doing it for a reason right they
need the benefit of the energy drink
whatever that is but
but it's like that's not it's a problem
it's a problem and and all of a sudden
like that like with a snap of the
fingers you can actually
you can actually still get the benefits
with no downside no that's freaking
crazy no problem
yeah yeah same thing with dessert
all the benefits sweetness goodness
filling
uh uh let's face it there's a certain
texture too like that you kind of you
know you want that mole
oh yeah
i'm getting crazy no but but it's all
true so you know
does that go against the whole hey man
the path is hard
embrace the hardness okay but here's
here's the dichotomy you turned me onto
this
okay it's a big deal this is a big deal
too okay oh geez
i think i thought bh ladell hart had
some info for us today but apparently
echo charles are coming in
with the facts the truth i'm doing the
best i can talk through here to benefit
the group
um look our
the goal isn't to drink milk that's not
the goal it's a means
to an end i'm learning too okay
check so the milk is the protein to help
us recover from our workouts
right you see insane yeah right getting
jacked so it's more efficient
why should we fight that battle well we
don't have to
the same scene cool take them all no
battle no factor yeah
easy money boom win without a fight
we're not choking down
some crap yeah some chalky
how much do you look forward to mulk
very much so i look for i'm
i get super amped oh yeah and it's the
kind
and this is good enough i had a milk
before we changed it actually
normally i don't do that but i don't
know before we train today because
i got done with ef online at like what
12 30
and we weren't going to train until 2 30
like
you know because normally i don't eat
until after the train
but today again it was calling you you
know how certain desserts call your name
that's what was happening to you yeah
yeah i understand i understand fully but
guess what no problem
this path that we're on just got a
little bit easier so you don't have to
worry about that anymore
so yes like i said immediately i got you
got immunity stuff as well cold war
uh vitamin d3 boom take that i'll
guarantee you your path would be a
little bit easier versus if you don't
take now we're not getting sick all of a
sudden negative
which we like we don't like to worry
about you can get this you can get the
drinks at wawa by the way on the east
coast if you're on the east coast you go
to wawa
get yourself you can clear out shelves
whatever that's kind of like what we're
doing
sanctioned really sanctioned authorized
yeah authorized
cory my boy cory my cousin corey rolled
in with an actual
cooler to a wawa and just started
clearing shelves straight up
like what yeah that's what we're doing
the worker's just looking at him like
he's a cycle yeah
uh you get a huawei you can get this
stuff at vitamin shop vitamin shop has
the whole line of uh
the supplements yeah so you can go to
vitamin shop or you go to
jackalfield.com
and get some if you want some yep and if
you're interested in a little
discount little free shipping a little
not having to worry about remembering to
make sure you're always stocked
mm-hmm get the subscription path just
got a little easier easier
even because the path just got even
easier more efficient we're not
remembering we're not worried about it
we're more efficient
we can focus on something else no
distraction
technically bh ladel heart would be like
oh you got a distraction going are you
going to write down remember to order no
we'll just eliminate that
we can focus our efforts exactly right
100 in a way it's decentralized command
2 because pete guy's over there they're
over
they're taking over that's their jam now
yeah and their country for you
so you can go move elsewhere exactly all
kinds of music
you can subscribe is what we're saying
yes sir get free shipping
check yep it's true also originusa.com
this is where you can get your
american-made
goods durable goods as it were but what
that means is you can get american-made
denim
jeans a few models there we've got delta
68 in the
factory factory yeah boom and you say
factory like
they don't i was at the ud udtc museum
in fort pierce florida yeah hell yeah
and yeah it's awesome
and they had a guy they had uh
was like a statue no it's not a statue
it's a mannequin
is there a word for that mannequin okay
there's a mannequin but he's dressed up
like a
like a nom seal and straight up just
wearing jeans
just straight up that's what he's in the
case you know the glass case
right right like uh like a like an
action figure
yeah a big one like a life yeah
yeah you can get so we made those delta
68s because i know
look i'm probably gonna be living
multiple lives you know i'll be back
here as
another fighter another war and when i
come back
it's probably going to be back in nam
again could be possibly i don't know if
the jungle
i'm going to wear jeans and i'm going to
wear delta 68 jeans and i just want the
world to know that
it makes sense and like i said they all
are made in america from the
even the raw materials the dirt to the
shirt they're to the shirt or the jeans
as the case may be also there's belts on
there there's some cool wallets on there
hoodies athletic wear anyway there's a
lot of stuff on there
you get what it's all made in america
all made in america originusa.com
also good news we have our own store
we've been had our own store since
day one which is again good news just in
case you didn't know was it day one
day eight okay i think okay
maybe i don't know one of the early days
we'll say that it's called jocko
store so you go to jackostore.com and
this is where you can get your
shirts hats hoodies rash guards this
kind of stuff discipline equals freedom
represent
while we're on the path so boom not only
did the path get
a little bit easier got a little bit
cooler dude
that's my opinion johnstore.com um oh
also we have
a subscription situation as well it's
called the shirt
locker this is all the shirts that you
may or may not see
me sometimes dave burke now carrie
wearing where you're like oh i didn't
see that shirt on the store
and you're like oh where do i get that
one where do i get that one i know i'm
saying this because people are
literally saying that to me or whatever
you go to the shirt locker
and you and you subscribe that's where
you get those shirts so yeah the designs
are more um how should i say a little
bit off
off straight and narrow and more
creative especially i can say it right
now
unless it's called the shirt locker so
subscribe for that one if you want
okay yeah and by the way you can scrub
to this podcast
you can also check out jocko unraveling
which i'm doing with daryl cooper we're
going hard
in the paint with that one we got the
grounded podcast we got the warrior kid
podcast which i know i owe you also got
the jocko
underground the underground podcast
where we're
we're doing amplifying information
we're doing a lot of q a on that one
because we have a little direct
methodology you can ask questions so
we're doing a lot of q
a bro yo you've been giving some good
advice on that one and speaking from my
position personally that one about the
um
13 year old kids right the teachers
trying to control the class and
like sometimes they're kind of they get
kind of crazy sometimes but it's like
man
they kind of get crazy some like what do
i do how do i deal with that man that
was a good one
it was really good and a lot of that is
yeah
it's just good questions coming in so
hey if you want to get to
if you want to listen to that we set
this up because we need to have some
kind of an alternative platform
in case in case in case what well
contingencies happen
what if what if some of these platforms
decide to start charging you money
what if some of these platforms decide
to start interjecting their own
advertisements
into them what if they just straight up
censor us because they don't like what
we're talking about any of these things
could happen
if those things happen we wanted to have
our own
backup plan so we have one
jockowunderground.com
it costs 8 dollars and 18 cents a month
to support the cause
and if you can't afford it no factor
we're the reason this isn't like
oh we don't want you in the game we want
you in the game
if you can't afford it email assistance
jockowunderground.com
and we'll take care we also have a
youtube channel that you can
also subscribe to if you want to see my
assistant director
skills which are in action in action
on that origin usa also has a youtube
channel if you want to see main ties
skills doing some good work up there
main tie yep
let's talk them today about some stuff i
won't go into it anytime
all day yeah also psychological warfare
if you don't know what that is it's an
album
jocko album with tracks jocko tracks
telling you
us how to get past and through our
moments of weakness
make them be less of a factor on this
path
boom got a little bit easier again now
you got jocko there
supplements that taste good no factor
and
boom you can just keep rolling on that
path a little bit easier a little bit
more luxurious
you can also get flipsidecanvas.com
dakota myers company he's putting stuff
to hang on your wall
stuff that's cool made check it out we
got a bunch of books
final spin got a novel coming
about novel stuff no stuff
have you read the late have you read the
final dave
i don't know i i've read i think you
might have made a couple of small edits
since then what's your assessment you
know what my assessment is
the better assessment was my wife i was
gonna say what about your wife's
assessment
that was the real assessment yeah
because she has no uh zero
skin and or not skin in the game no
loyalty yeah
in fact she's sick of hearing about me
she's probably looking to drop the
hammer what was her assessment
well the best assessment was uh
she finished it in two sittings wow and
that's like
going to bed i'm gonna crack the book
open i'm like hey just hey read this
tell me what you think kind of scenario
not like a big pressure move
and um she kind of got through two two
thirds of it and then the next night
finished and she's like that was really
good
like that the the finished book in a day
in two readings like two sittings uh
speaks
volumes that's a good deal it's good uh
so that's coming out actually the date
change on when it comes out
it's coming out now no it's coming out a
little bit earlier okay
yeah seems like the demand is kind of
kicking
good looks like we're moving that right
i think it's november
6 now no so if you want that
you know the deal if you want that first
edition leadership strategy and tactics
field manual the code the evaluation the
protocols discipline was freedom field
field manual
way the warrior kid one two three and
four
about face we talked about it today
mikey and the dragons
liking the dragons it's incredible how
often i have to talk about mikey on the
mikey and the dragons i'm gonna explain
that story to
adults because people like i'm afraid to
do this i'm afraid to do that it's like
oh it's a
common question and even from leaders
like i'm afraid to address this it's
like
all the time how about face hackers we
talked about it today and then
extreme ownership and the dichotomy of
leadership we have a leadership
consultant
consultancy we solve problems through
leadership if you want to check that out
go to echelonfront.com
we have online training as well it's
like a
leadership gym
right with trainers yeah with trainers
what do you just think you're going to
just stay in shape by sitting at home
no you got to go to the gym how's your
leadership going to get better how's
your leadership just going to even
stay at a good level got to go to the
leadership gym
that's what we've got efonline.com
yeah efonline.com extreme ownership
academy so
if you want to learn about leadership
code we got courses on there we're doing
live stuff all the time
we're doing live stuff all the time you
want to ask me a question go there i'll
answer your question and i'll actually
dig down and dave will come in off the
top ropes life will be flanking the
whole situation
like we're there and we have the muster
we just got done with orlando next
muster is phoenix
in august august 17th and 18th las vegas
october 28th and 29th go to
extremeownership.com
everything we've done is sold out so if
you want to come
go and register we also have ef
battlefield we also hate
if battlefield we don't have one on the
calendar right now the next thing we do
have on the calendar is
ftx where you're gonna put on gear
laser tag gear we have this high speed
laser tag system and you're going to run
operations and learn these leadership
lessons the next one we're doing is in
san diego day go
right here in sd yes sir july 12th and
13th
so if you want to come there's only 32
seats for that we haven't really talked
about it
yet so we kind of we kind of turned it
on when they started filling up we
filled up another one so
here we go july 12th and 13th ftx in san
diego
you're going to run operations you're
going to put these principles to use
give it
check it out and then if you want to
help service members you want to help
service members active
and retired their families gold star
families check out
mark lee's mom mama lee heard she's got
a charity organization doing all kinds
of great work for veterans one of the
main things she's doing is getting
medical treatments for our vets that
maybe
aren't being covered by the va if you
want to donate or you want to get
involved
go to americasmightywarriors.org
and if you want more of my protracted
pontifications
or you need more of echo's misplaced
meanderings or perhaps even more of
dave's
animated editions you can find us on the
interwebs
on twitter on the gram and on facebook
echo is adequate charles
dave is at david r burke and i am at
jocko willink
and to the military service men and
women out there
thank you for putting the strategy of
freedom into tactics and keeping
the world from darkness same goes to our
police and law enforcement firefighters
paramedics
emts dispatchers correctional officers
border patrol secret service and all
first responders
thanks for keeping the world safe from
evil
here at home and everyone else out there
the direct approach is not as direct as
you think
so think again and maybe maybe just try
taking
the long way around because the long way
around you might find out
ends up being the shortest distance
between
two points
until next time this is dave and echo
and jocko